JUDICIARY TODAY'S TUESDAY APRIL
SEVENTEENTH WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO WILL START AS A.
SUBCOMMITTEE NORMALLY I'M.
LOS THE START WITHOUT AT LEAST A
REPUBLICAN MEMBER HERE. WE HAVE
A BUSY AGENDA TODAY SO I'M GONNA
GET STARTED ANYWAY.
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER.
TO WHICH IS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
MISTER QUIRK.
FOR.
YEAH.
THANK YOU CHAIR IT'S A BUSY TIME
OF YEAR I KNOW I HAVE.
OTHER BILLS TO PRESENT IN THE
COMMITTEE TO BE AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR STARTING ON
TIME.
A AB NINETEEN EIGHTY EXTENDS A
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
COMMENCING SEVERAL ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS.
FOR ABOVE GROUND PETROLEUM
STORAGE ACT OR A P. S. A..
BOB BENNETT EXTENDS THAT
ENFORCE.
STANDS THAT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FROM ONE YEAR TO
FIVE YEARS.
SPELLS FROM PETROLEUM TANKS
THERE'S JUST TO HAVE YOU HERE
YOU BOTH KNOW WHAT THE BILL IS
ABOUT.
I THINK I CAN STOP AT THAT POINT
AND SAVE.
I KNOW.
SO I WILL JUST YOU TO KNOW THE
BILL VERY WELL ANYONE WHO ISN'T
HERE.
ISN'T GOING TO HEAR WHAT I'M
GONNA SAY SO I WILL GIVE THIS
OVER TO KEVIN WONG FROM THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I KICKED FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE
YOU ARE GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS KEVIN WONG I'M A
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY.
ATTORNEYS OFFICE.
I'M APPEARING.
ON BEHALF OF NANCY O'MALLEY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY. AND THAT SPONSORED THIS
BILL.
.
AB SAID IS AN IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL.
LAW.
OTHER AREAS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW INCLUDING HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL LAW HAS HIS PICTURE OF
BUSINESS PLAN.
AN UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS
BENEFIT FROM A FIVE YEAR STATUTE
LIMITATIONS.
SO THIS BILL WOULD BRING ABSENT
OTHER IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW.
ON PAR WITH THE FIVE YEAR
STATUTE LIMITATIONS
SO MAKE IT CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
AREAS OF ENVIRONMENTAL LAW.
IN ADDITION TO THIS CONSISTENCY.
AYE IT ALSO REFLECTS THE
REALITIES OF HOW.
THESE CASES ARE INVESTIGATED.
YEAH AND ENFORCE
THESE CASES COME TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES AND OTHER
PROSECUTORS. AFTER ONLY BEING
OBSERVED BY ENVIRONMENTAL%
REGULATORS.
AND THEN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
USE THEIR OWN ADMINISTRATIVE
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS.
TO TRY AND GET BUSINESSES INTO
COMPLIANCE
AND ONLY AFTER THEY FAIL DEBATE
REFERRED THESE CASES TO
PROSECUTORS
SO THEY COME TO DA'S OFFICES.
ANA DELAYED SCHEDULED TO BEGIN
WITH.
ONCE THEY COME TO OUR OFFICES.
WE DO FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
IT TAKES MORE TIME.
WE LOOK AT OTHER VIOLATIONS.
IN ADDITION TO ABOVE GROUND
STORAGE TANK VIOLATIONS.
.
IT IS A VERY COMPLEX CASES
AND.
.
EXTENDING THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS WILL GIVE US MORE
TIME TO.
EFFECTIVELY ENFORCE THESE CASES
AND MAKE SOUND JUDGMENTS
WE'RE WE'RE NOT RUSHED
TO DO SO.
SO RESPECTFULLY THAT WE WOULD
REQUEST THAT YOUR AYE BOTH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MARIE WOULDN'T I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA UNIFIED
PROGRAM FORM BOARD.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
BACKGROUND PETROLEUM STORAGE
ACT.
ABSA IS ONE OF THE SIX STATE
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IMPLEMENTED BY THE
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT ARE CALLED
TO UNIFY PROGRAM AGENCIES.
THE ABSA PROGRAM BECAME LAW
BECAUSE MAJOR OR THERE WAS A
MAJOR OIL SPILL A MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA THAT IMPACTED A
MARTIAN THEM FLOWED OUT INTO
THIS IS SOON BAKER. KING IT
STRAIGHT
IT BECAME PART OF THE UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCY LOOK. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE REQUIREMENTS OF
ABSENT OR TO IMPLEMENT FEDERAL
LAW FOR ABOVE GROUND STORAGE
TANKS THAT STORE PETROLEUM
PRODUCTS WE SPILL COULD IMPACT
THE WATERS OF THE STATE.
UNIFIED PROGRAM AGENCY
INSPECTORS ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE
A TRAINING AND PASS TESTS PRIOR
TO BEING ABLE TO EXPECT INSPECT
THESE SITES.
THE INSPECTORS ARE ALSO TRAINED
A PERFORMING INSPECTIONS AND
DOING ENFORCEMENT WHERE THERE
ARE VIOLATIONS.
I'M FOR THE FIVE OF THE SIX
PROGRAMS THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IT'S FIVE YEARS THE
ABSA PROGRAM STATUTE LIMITATION
IS ONE YEAR WHEN THERE IS A
COMPLEX ENFORCEMENT CASE WHERE
THERE ARE MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS
THAT ARE IN. MORE THAN ONE
PROGRAM AND WHEN THERE ARE
MULTIPLE AGENCIES INVOLVED.
ONE YEAR IS NOT LONG ENOUGH TO
DEVELOP A WELL THOUGHT OUT AND
BUYING AND THE FINE CASE. A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY WILL ALIGN THE
STATUE LIMITATIONS FOR APPS THAT
WITH THE OTHER FIVE UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCY PROGRAMS.
BUT THAT.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WITH US
BUT WHAT ELSE IS THERE ANY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT AND WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SING NONE.
QUIRK.
WELL BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IF QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SCORE CAN MAKE CLOTHES
ALL QUIT WHILE I'M AHEAD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU WILK.
I THINK A MOTION WHEN WE GET TO
WILL WE GET A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
RIGHT MISTER SANTIAGO.
YOU HAVE A COUPLE BILLS WITH US
TODAY.
SO LET'S TAKE ITEM NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS A BE NINETEEN FORTY
NINE.
THERE'S A CHAIR PREFER WERE
BRIEF.
FOR OUR ENTIRE PRESENTATION.
WELL.
CHAIR PERVERT.
BREVITY BUT IT'S YOUR
PRESENTATION.
STILL ONE OF.
OR FOR BREVITY TO BUT.
I THOUGHT FOR SO I THINK BE A
COMMITTEE AND FOR HELPING US TO
MAKE THIS A BETTER BILL. I
ACCEPT ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ARE THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
WE.
WE TOOK NOTICE WHEN I'M MISTER
MUST.
I IN A BILL THE BILLIONAIRE
INVESTOR INTENDED TO SELL. OFF
FLAMETHROWERS AT ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED BUCKS A POP IN ORDER TO
RAISE MONEY FOR OTHER PROJECTS.
WE WERE ALARMED BECAUSE WE FELT
THAT THIS WAS A A WEAPON.
I COULD POTENTIALLY BE USED NOT
ONLY CAUSE BODILY HARM BUT ALSO.
CAUSE FIRES AND SO WE STARTED
ON A PATH TOWARDS A.
TRYING TO BAN THEM AND.
.
DUE TO COUPLE DIFFERENT THE.
A COMMITTEES AND DIFFERENT
MOMENTS CONVERSATION THE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE AND NOW WE'RE
HERE.
PRESENTING A BILL THAT WOULD
ONLY PUT LABELS.
TO SHOW THE HARM THAT COULD BE
MADE FROM THESE UP PRODUCTS.
WAY. HOW WHEN? THEY MISTER.
I THINK YOU GIVE ANY WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
NOPE.
I IT WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
THE NON BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
BUT THAT MIGHT MAKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE
BUT WHEN YOU HIT QUORUM THANK
YOU.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY.
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HUH
WE ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT I THINK YOU
CAN BE STAFF WORKING.
WITH OUR OFFICE AND SPONSORS AS
AMENDED.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY WOULD EXTEND
THE SENSE THAT DEEPER FIVE YEARS
THE CALIFORNIA UNLAWFUL DETAINER
PILOT PROGRAM.
WITH ME I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WILL ALSO BE BRIEF WHICH I THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE OF CITY ATTORNEY MIKE LOS
ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE FEAR.
A WERE SPONSORS OF THE BILL THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN. IN EFFECT
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
A FEW YEARS INTO THE PERSON
THAT THEY'RE IN IT ORIGINATED
WITH.
AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTION
RELATED TO ARRESTS AND
COMPLAINTS REGARDING CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
THE QUICKLY OF FIRE AT
COMPLAINTS RELATING TO FIRE ARMS
AND AMMUNITION.
WAS ADDED THE CODE SECTION WAS
ADDED TO STATE LAW.
THIS HAS SERVED AS A VERY
EFFECTIVE TOOL IN OUR BAKER TOOL
BOX
TO CUT DOWN ON THESE NUISANCES
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND. TO
REALLY GET RID OF THESE PROBLEM.
.
CRIMINAL ELEMENTS FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES SO WE ARE HERE TO
ASK FOR.
AN EXTENSION A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION I'M WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT THROUGHOUT THE LIFE OF THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN EVALUATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BUREAU.
THEY HAVE COLLECTED DATA FROM.
LOCALS EVERY FEW YEARS AND.
THEY HAVE PROVIDED A PRETTY
CLEAN AND CONCISE EVALUATION OF
THE PROGRAM SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK. NEXT WITH.
GUSTAVO MARTINEZ SAMBA
SUPERVISING DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY
HERE IN THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
AND.
I'VE BEEN.
PART OF THIS PROGRAM PILOT
PROGRAM SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
OUT IN SACRAMENTO AND IT'S A.
WONDERFUL.
TOOL. OF FOR PROSECUTORS INTO
AND CIVIL ATTORNEYS LIKE MYSELF
THAT THE.
THAT USE THE CIVIL ARENA AND TO.
MOVE DRUG DEALERS AND GANGSTERS
AT OF.
DISADVANTAGED NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO IT'S A IT'S A GOOD TOOL AND
SUPPORT THE LANDLORDS WHO ARE A
TIMES VICTIMIZED AND THREATENED
BY GANG MEMBERS FOR. EVEN A
THREATENING EVICTION.
AS SO WERE ABLE TO STEP INTO THE
SHOES OF THOSE LANDLORDS THEY'RE
FEARFUL. OF RETALIATION AND
SUPPORT THEM
IN EVICTING PEOPLE WITH FIREARMS
AND THAT AND CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES SO. I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ON THE PROGRAM. AND THE I
ONE THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
SANTIAGO FOR SPONSORING THIS AND
THEM. WILL WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BUT I'VE NEVER CARL TO
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE TO
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE WE BELIEVE
THIS KEEPS OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
SAFE IT DOES HELP RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS WHEN THEY CAN
WORK WITH LOCAL PROSECUTORS. HOT
ON THE ADDICTION PROCESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLAY GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARIA BE I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. THE CITY
OF OAKLAND HAS BEEN A
PARTICIPANT AND THE PILOT
PROGRAM SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND WERE STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
PROGRAM AND THE LAW. AND THIS IS
A VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL THAT WE
USE TO DEAL WITH NUISANCE
INFECTIONS AND WE USE IT
JUDICIOUSLY AND WISELY AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISSOURI.
I NOTICE THAT THERE ONLY FOR
COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN USING
THIS.
I ASSUME IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
IT IT ARE THERE ANY INTENTIONS
OF.
EXTENDING IT TO OTHER COUNTIES
OR TO THE STATE.
CARLSON I'LL ANSWER FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I MEAN IN A PERFECT
WORLD.
SURE.
WE DECIDED JUST TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH A SUNSET AT LEAST ME IN
THEY CAN ANSWER LEVITICAL AND
WOOD DECIDED TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE SUNSET.
BECAUSE THESE OF THE COUNTIES
THAT ARE NEED A ALREADY THERE
AND I DO WANT TO RUB ANY
CONCERNS ON FOLKS TO THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO.
OUTRIGHT IF IT FOLKS BUT THE
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS REALLY
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GET RID OF
FOLKS WHO TERRORIZE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
NOW I UNDERSTAND AND. BUT
THEY'RE ONLY FOR COUNTIES
HOUSTON I THOUGHT
IT'S A.
AFTER. AFTER TEN YEARS WE KNOW
WHETHER IT'S SUCCESSFUL OR NOT
AND FIT SUCCESSFUL VAN. UP
PERHAPS OF THE COUNTIES I'D BE
OVERNIGHT I'D LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TAUGHT THE SPONSORS
AND AND.
TALK TO THE CHAIR AND OTHERS
ABOUT THAT I A ONE WEEK DECISION
RIGHT AWAY BUT. IT WORKS IN MY
COUNTY I LIVE IN MEANING MY CITY
SIDE.
UPSET SUPPORT. CRICKET.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
ALRIGHT SINGER MISTER SANTIAGO
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE
QUORUM THANK YOU THINK WELL.
THANK YOU.
SO THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN A. B.. THIRTY TO
TWELVE MISSOURI.
MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
THIRTY TO TWELVE UPDATES EXPANDS
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY AND
VETERANS CODE TO INCREASE.
MILITARY CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
ORDER TO MORE EFFICIENTLY
SAFEGUARD OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES MISTER IS
THAT.
THEY GIVE THE CLOSER TO MY PHONE
DOESN'T HAVE THAT IT'S HARD FOR
YOU. HELLO THERE WE GO OUTSIDE.
I WILL NOT START OVER.
UNDER CURRENT LAW MANY OF THE
PROTECTIONS IN CODE QUICKLY
EXPIRE AFTER SERVICE MEMBER
LEAVES ACTIVE DUTY AB THIRTY TO
TWELVE WILL HELP THOSE WHO
STRUGGLE TO RE INTEGRATE. AFTER
RETURNING FROM DEPLOYMENT BY
EXTENDING THE TIME FRAME THAT
SERVICE MEMBERS RECEIVE
PROTECTION AGAINST EVICTION AND
NON. A JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE FOR
UP TO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS
AFTER LEAVING ACTIVE DUTY. THE
BILL ALSO ADDS THAT OUR STATE'S
FULL TIME ACTIVE COMPONENT
PERSONNEL RECEIVE EQUIVALENT
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL SERVICE MEMBERS CIVIL
RELIEF ACT.
WE MUST DO OUR PART AS STATE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS TO
BETTER PROTECT THESE MEN AND
WOMEN AFTER AND IN BETWEEN.
PERIODS OF SERVICE.
I HAVE WITH ME.
TWO WITNESSES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHARLES
HARVEY A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE UP
WITH THE OFFICE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL. I HAVE IF ETCETERA
SPONSORED A AB THIRTY TO TWELVE.
ON BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE LIKE I THINK
THE MEMBER IRWIN FOR LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA FOR AUTHORING IS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AB THIRTY TO TWELVE IS A
SENSIBLE CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE SIX EASE THE LEGAL AND
FINANCIAL BURDENS PLACED ON
CALIFORNIA SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES BROUGHT ON BY THE
DEMANDS OF ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE.
THE BILL ALSO AIMS TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A LOT LEAST AS
PROTECTIVE
FOR SERVICE MEMBERS THAT THE
CORRESPONDING FEDERAL LAW.
I THE STANDS TODAY MANY OF THE
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED.
TO OUR SERVICE MEMBERS UNDER
STATE LAW EXPIRE QUICKLY AFTER
SERVICE MEMBER LEAVE ACTIVE
DUTY.
OUR THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
SERVICE MEMBERS NEED TIME AFTER
DEPLOYMENT TO REINTEGRATE AND
MAY FACE FINANCIAL DISTRESS
DURING THIS PERIOD OF
TRANSITION.
AB THERE DOES TWELVE WOULD
EXTEND THE LENGTH OF TIME
SERVICE MEMBERS RECEIVE VARIOUS
PROTECTIONS ALGUNOS GETS THE
BALL JUDGMENT ON JUDICIAL
FORECLOSURE.
TOOK TWO HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
AFTER LEAVING ACTIVE DUTY.
THE BILL ALSO INCORPORATES IN
THE STATE LAW SOME PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY ONLY FOUND IN
FEDERAL AT SEE. INCLUDING RIGHT
TO TERMINATE A MOTOR VEHICLE
LEASES EXPANDED PROTECTIONS
AGAINST LEAN SALES AND MAKING
CLEAR THAT INTEREST ABOVE SIX
PERCENT CAP ON PRE SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS FORGIVEN AND NOT
MERELY DEFERRED.
AND LASTLY OUR STATE LAWS
CURRENT MILITARY CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS APPLY ONLY TO
MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL GUARD
AND RESERVE COMPONENTS.
SO THEY DO NOT EXTEND TO THE
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND A
FULL TIME MEMBERS OF THE ACTIVE
COMPONENT OF THE ARMED FORCES
LIVING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I BE THERE TO SEE TWELVE
ADDRESSES ITS MISSION BY MAKING
THE STATE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AVAILABLE TO ALL MEMBERS OF THE
ARMED FORCES INCLUDING ACTIVE
COMPONENT PERSONNEL.
TAKEN TOGETHER THESE PROPOSED
CHANGES IN THE BILL WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TOWARD BETTER
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA SERVICE
MEMBERS INCLUDING DURING BOTH
CRITICAL POST DEPLOYMENT AND
POST SEPARATION PERIODS. I'M
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE NICK ACRE
IS A MEMBER OF THE STATE
MILITARY RESERVE AND THE SENIOR
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
OVERSEES THE DOJ'S CONSUMER LAW
SECTION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF MY NAME IS NICK
ACRES AND THE SENIOR ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CHARGE OF
THE CONSUMER LAW SECTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE.
I'VE ALSO SERVED FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS AS A JUDGE ADVOCATE AND
LEGAL ASSISTANCE ATTORNEY FOR
THE CALPERS STATE MILITARY
RESERVE AND SPENT MUCH OF THAT
TIME WORKING WITH THE SOLDIERS
AND AIRMEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD. ON INDIVIDUAL
LEGAL CONCERNS AT THE FACE
DURING DEPLOYMENT. OF THE LAST
FIVE YEARS OUR CONSUMER LAW
SECTION HAS UNDERTAKEN A
TARGETED EFFORT TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MILITARY AND
VETERAN COMMUNITIES. AND THAT'S
INCLUDE OUT INCLUDE OUTREACH
TRAINING FOR JACK LEGAL
ASSISTANCE ATTORNEYS AND
FINANCIAL COUNSELORS. AND
TARGETED LAWSUITS AND CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS UNDER OUR MILITARY
AND VETERANS CODE AND OTHER
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS. UNDER
NUMBER OF THIS CASE IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF REFERRALS FROM OUR
PARTNERS IN THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS COMMUNITY.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I AB
THIRTY TO TWELVE IS A PRODUCT OF
THAT EXPERIENCE IN THE OF THE
INSIGHTS AND FEEDBACK WE RECEIVE
FROM OUR PARTNERS IN THE JAG
LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND MILITARY
FINANCIAL COUNSELOR COMMUNITIES.
INFIRMITY JEWEL SERVICE MEMBERS
AND VETERANS WHO CONTACTED OUR
OFFICE.
.
AS MISTER HERBIE INDICATED AB%
THIRTY TO TWELVE WOULD WOULD
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S MILITARY
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN TWO WAYS
FIRST IT WOULD MAKE OUR EXISTING
LOT MORE EFFECTIVE BY FILLING
GAPS.
AND ENSURING THEIR LAW REMAINS
AS EFFECTIVE AS THE FEDERAL
SERVICE MEMBERS CIVIL RELIEF
ACT.
AND IT WOULD ALSO EXTEND THE
DURATION OF THIS PERIOD OF THE
DURATION OF THOSE PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING THE PROTECTIONS
AGAINST FORECLOSURE AFFECTIONATE
REPOSSESSION.
TO HELP SERVICE MEMBERS WHEN
THEY TRANSACT TRANSITION BACK TO
CIVILIAN LIFE.
IN ADDITION IT WOULD EXTEND THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE CURRENT
STATUTE WHICH CURRENTLY ONLY
COVER MEMBERS OF THE GUARD AND
RESERVE.
TO COVER MEMBERS OF THE ACTIVE
COMPONENTS OF THE ARMED FORCES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS LEGISLATION AND
WE'D BE GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
THAT STEVE CREWS ON BEHALF OF
ENCORE CAPITAL. BUNKER CAPITAL
IS THE LARGEST PURCHASER OF DEBT
IN THE COUNTRY THERE BASED A
CALIFORNIAN SAN DIEGO.
WE'D I HAVE SIMILAR PROGRAMS TO
WHAT'S OFFERED IN AB THIRTY TO
TWELVE.
TERMS OF OFFERINGS HARDSHIP
SEATING OF COLLECTIONS FOR OUR
MILITARY AND VETERANS.
AB THIRTY TO TWELVE FURTHER
THOSE EFFORTS AND WE ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THE NEW US AND SUPPORT YOU JUST
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE MY NAME IS
SETH GREEN WAS READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS.
HOUSE AND REPRESENT
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMANDERS VETERANS COUNCIL.
IN THE MILITARY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA COUNT
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
ALL IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
THING NONE BRING BACK FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SINGER LOSER WHEN YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU WE DON'T YET HAVE
A QUORUM SO WE'LL TAKE IT UP TO
THE FARM SOON AS WE DO.
THANK YOU.
HI.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR
WIENER.
BOARDING
.
FAIR OR MY WITNESSES SHE TURNED
IT SHOULD BE HERE.
LOOKING FOR THEM NOW.
MISTER THANK YOU FOR SCHEDULING
THIS BILL.
TODAY I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF OF FOUR.
STEPS ATTENTION AND SUGGESTIONS
ON THE BILL OVER INCORPORATING
ODDS TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
AMENDMENTS THAT STEM FROM
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE STATE BAR.
OF CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS.
ASSOCIATION.
MEMBERS SP SEVENTY FIVE I MAKES
A PROCEDURAL A CHANGE OF THE
EVIDENCE CODE OUGHT TO PREVENT.
IRRELEVANT INFORMATION ABOUT
IMMIGRATION STATUS UP FROM BEING
RAISED AYE IN OPEN COURT. AYE
THIS PROCEDURAL CHANGE OUR DOES
NOT AYE.
EXCLUDE EVIDENCE IS NOT
CHANGING WHAT'S ADMISSIBLE OR
WHAT'S AND ADMISSIBLE. ABBOTT
SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT IF AN
ATTORNEY WHETHER IN A CIVIL CASE
OR CRIMINAL CASE WHICH IS TO
QUESTION A WITNESS ABOUT HIS OR
HER. IMMIGRATION STATUS ODD BAIT
AGUILLAR FIRST HAVE TO GO IN
CAMERA.
WITH THE JUDGE MAKE A PROPER
ABOUT WHY IT'S RELEVANT THE
JUDGE WILL MAKE A RULING AND
THAT IT WILL EITHER BE ALLOWED.
OR NOT ALLOWED.
THIS WILL.
OF BUOYED.
THAT SITUATION THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
IT NOT JUST IN SAN FRANCISCO
BUT WE'RE HEARING ABOUT AND
OTHER COUNTIES AS WELL.
WHERE?
IMMIGRANTS COME TESTIFYING COR
FATHER ASKED ABOUT THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
SOMETIMES IN VERY IRRELEVANT
SITUATIONS.
I AND IT IS AYE INTIMIDATING.
I AND.
WE KNOW THAT I USE IS NOT IN
OUR COURTHOUSES.
I AND THE LAST THING WE NEED IS
A MATTER PUBLIC SAFETY IS FOR
IMMIGRANTS TO BELIEVE THAT IF
THEY GO TO COURT TO TESTIFY.
WHETHER THE VICTIM WHETHER THE
WITNESS THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
GET DEPORTED WE WE WE GOT WILL
UNDERMINE. OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
I'D THIS I KNEW PROCEDURAL RULE
ARE IS NO DIFFERENT THAN THE
ROLE IT'S ALREADY IN PLACE.
IN.
RAPE PROSECUTIONS
I WHEN.
THE VICTIM OF A RAPIST
TESTIFYING I CAN'T JUST ASK THAT
WITNESS THAT VICTIM ABOUT HIS OR
HER SEXUAL HISTORY YOU'RE GONNA
DO THAT YOU HAVE TO GO IN
CAMERA.
WITH THE COURT FIRST AND MAKE A
PROFFER FOR WHY IT'S RELEVANT TO
THIS IS NOT UNPRECEDENTED.
AND IT MAKES ALL THE SENSE I IN
THE WORLD HERE.
.
ARE WE HAVE GOT AND.
GROWING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS NOT SABOT ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
THANK YOU AND SENATOR THERE ARE
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT ARE FOR AN
AMENDMENT THAT'S ADDRESSED IN
THE.
ANALYSIS AND AND I THINK OF YOUR
TAKING OF THAT WE ACCEPT THAT
YES AND ALSO WITH ME TODAY IS
CHRYSANTHOS.
FROM THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS.
FIRST WITH FLEAS
I THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
MAX SZABO AND I'M FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO PETRONIUS OFFICE. AND
WE WANNA THANK GOD SENATOR
WINNER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW WE'RE SEEING DEPRESSED
REPORTING AMONG IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE AS
WELL.
AROUND AND WHEN ANYBODY DOES NOT
FEEL COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD
IN REPORTING A CRIME LET ALONE
TAKING THE NEXT STEP IN TAKING
THE WITNESS STAND. ON THAT
IMPACTS THE FAIR ADMINISTRATION
OF JUSTICE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE FEEL SAFE COMING TO THE
COURT TOWARD CUP TORE COURTS.
I MEAN THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
A COURT ROOMS.
AND WHAT THIS BILL BASICALLY
DOES IS JUST AVOID.
BE UNNECESSARY COURTROOM DRAMA
WHERE SOMEBODY.
BRINGS EXPLOSIVE EVIDENCE
THAT'S COMPLETELY IRRELEVANT TO
THE MATTER AT HAND. I AND REALLY
IF THAT EVIDENCE DOES NEED TO
COME IN IF IT IS RELEVANT.
WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING THAT A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY OR A
PROSECUTOR.
MAKE SURE THAT THAT ALTHOUGH X.
EVIDENCE IS RELEVANT BEFORE THEY
BRING IT AND.
ESPECIALLY IN AN ERA WHERE.
UNDOCUMENTED MIGRANTS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
I SAW OFFICERS BEING IN
COURTROOMS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
BELIEVE IS
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND WILL
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE.
THAT ALL PEOPLE WILL FEEL
COMFORTABLE COMING TO OUR
COURTHOUSES. TAKEN THE WITNESS
STAND IN PLAYING A ROLE IN THE
FAIR ADMINISTRATION JUSTICE.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS
PLEASE CHRIS RESPONSIBLE TRAILER
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND AWESTRUCK
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
.
SINCE OUR ELECTION OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP OF THAT REITERATED TIME
AFTER TIME COMMITTEE.
MANY IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
HESITANT TO AND TURN THE
COURTROOMS ARE BECAUSE OF THE
FEAR OF DEPORTATION BECAUSE OF
ICE OFFICERS. ARE WEARING OUR
NORMAL CLOTHING AND TRAIN AND
DETAINING INDIVIDUALS.
ON THIS EARLIER THIS YEAR I
DOUBLE DOWN AND I'M ROAD A
DIRECTIVE ITALIAN ICE OFFICERS
OUGHT NOT TO DETAIN INDIVIDUALS
INSIDE THE CORPORATE SAY THAT
WEREN'T TARGETED. ARM BUT THEY
WERE ABLE TO TARGET THAT THEIR
EFFORTS FOR TARGET FOLKS HOWEVER
ARE WE HAVE REPORTS THAT FOLKS
HAVE BEEN. ODD DETAINED UPON
FINDING OUT OF THEIR STATUS
WEREN'T TARGETED OUTSIDE THE
COURTS OUGHT TO KIND OF GO
AROUND THAT DIRECTIVE.
I THEREFORE WE CONTINUE THAT AMI
GAVE WITH OUR MEMBERSHIP IN THE
CONTINUE TO STATE THAT FAMILIES
ARE WILLING TO GO. OUGHT TO
COURT FOR EVEN THE SIMPLEST
THINGS THIS TRAFFIC COURT ARCHES
TO PAY A FINER ARE IFFY. ARE WE
BELIEVE THIS MEASURE SENDS A
STRONG MESSAGE TO ATTORNEYS
ACROSS THE STATE TO. ENSURE THAT
THE SITE SENSITIVE STATUS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S IS ARMED NOT USED
ON THAT SIDE NEEDED HOT FOR
THOSE REASONS WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
IN STRONG SUPPORTER SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THIS.
NO ONE IN SUPPORT.
OVER.
JERRY MEMBERS DOWN PUNK FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE COUNCIL HAD
SOME WORKABILITY CONCERNED WITH
EARLIER VERSIONS OF THE BILL. WE
WORK THROUGH THOSE ISSUES WITH
THE AUTHOR SPONSOR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
AND OF THE MOST RECENT SETS OF
AMENDMENT TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THEIR COOPERATIVE. EFFORT HERE
THE CURRENT VERSION AS WORKABLE
FOR THE COURTS.
THANK YOU.
OTHER THAN SUPPORT IF YOU JUST
GIVE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION. SYLVIA'S ALICIA ON
BEHALF THE SITTING COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING OR ATTEND IN BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHELLE THOMAS SHOT
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IT'S UNLIKELY.
I NICK BROKEN HERE FOR THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S ASSOCIATION.
WHERE TWEENER WE ARE JUST
PLEASED THOUGH TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION BE* ALL THAT THE
SUPPORT IT NOW HARD WORK AND
EFFORT ON THE? BOND UP. ON THE
PART OF FOLKS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SING NONE OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIMMY WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
.
BUT WE ARE STILL OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE
DETERMINATION ON THE RELEVANCE
OF SOMEONE'S TESTIMONY OR THEIR
CREDIBILITY.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
DONE IN OPEN COURT NOW WE
REALIZE THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN.
A REASONS WHY IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE THAT.
THERE'S A A NEED TO PROTECT.
FOLKS WHO COME FORWARD.
BECAUSE OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND BECAUSE OF THE.
ADMINISTRATIONS.
CHANGE IN POLICY WITH RESPECT
TO ON THE DEPORTATION OF
UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS
BUT WE THINK THAT THE CURRENT
RULES OF COURT PERMIT THAT TO
HAPPEN AND TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THERE'S INFORMATION THAT IS.
.
POSSIBLY.
IRRELEVANT OR INADMISSIBLE.
THAT.
ANY PARTY WHO ARE TO THE
PROCEEDING COULD RAISE THAT
OBJECTION AND THE COURT CAN DEAL
WITH IT IN THAT WAY.
I AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
TO REMAIN OPPOSED THANKS THANK
YOU.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE IT
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SING NONE OF BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND THE.
YEAH THE UP STATION RAISES AN
INTERESTING POINT WAS WERE DOING
EVERYTHING TO PROTECT FOLKS NOW
WHICH I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH.
BUT AT SOME POINT SOME OF THESE
RULES THEN
MAY OR MAY NOT BE AS NECESSARY
SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE
CONSCIOUS OF WHAT WE'RE.
DOING AND AND MAY NEED TO
REVISIT SOME
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND SOME
ARE GOING TO SURVIVE AS CONCERNS
AND PROTECTIONS THAT WILL
ABSOLUTELY.
NECESSARY SO I JUST THINK AS
WERE DOING BILLS LIKE THIS WE
NEED TO BE OF THE SOMEWHAT
SENSITIVE TO THESE THINGS.
THIS RACE THE MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU US CENTER WINNER I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD SOMETIMES WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE.
THE THE UNDERTONE OF IF THINGS
ARE HAPPY IN OUR COURT ROOM AND
I THINK THAT.
DOT COM AT THAT WAS MADE
EARLIER THAT CREDIBILITY ISSUES
SHOULD BE DISCUSSED IN OPEN
COURT WILL AGREE WITH THAT.
WHETHER SOMEBODY IS AN IMMIGRANT
OR NOT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
CREDIBILITY.
AND I THINK THAT I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE MISS THE MARK I THINK
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT.
ALL OF THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE
RELEVANT THEIR GOING TO BE
DISCUSSED IN OPEN COURT. BUT IF
IT IS IRRELEVANT TO CAN ONLY
CAUSE HARM TO SOMEONE HERE IN
IMMIGRANT.
BECAUSE HE WOULD BE USED
AGAINST THEM IN A WAY THAT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE CASE.
I AM VERY GLAD YOU BROUGHT
FORWARD I THINK IT ALSO GOES TO
THE FACT THAT.
SO MANY TIMES WE HAVE WITNESSES
AND EVEN VICTIMS WHO ARE NOT
WILLING TO COME FORWARD. AND IT
DOES BECOME A SAFETY ISSUE FOR
ALL OF US WHEN VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES ARE NOT WILLING TO
COME FORWARD BECAUSE OF THE HARM
THAT CAN BECOME TO THEM. OR TO
THEIR FAMILIES SO AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
THANK YOU SCAN HIM.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUICK
COMMENTS AND THEN.
TWO QUESTIONS.
ON THE COMMENT FRONT.
GLAD TO SEE THE DA'S ASSOCIATION
AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS BEHIND
A BILL THAT'S AN UNUSUAL
ALIGNMENT BUT I THINK THAT'S.
INDICATIVE OF IT BEING GOOD
POLICY I LIKE THE FACT.
I THINK IN MOST CIRCUMSTANCES
STATUS IS PROBABLY NOT BE
RELEVANT.
I THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE IT MIGHT BE.
ELEMENT OF A CRIME OR SOMETHING
OF THAT SORT.
OR POTENTIALLY RELEVANT TO
CREDIBILITY AND VERY ISOLATED
NARROW CIRCUMSTANCE I LIKE THE
FACT THAT THERE'S.
SO THAT.
AN INDIVIDUALIZED DETERMINATION
CAN BE MADE I THINK THAT'S
A POSITIVE THING AND I THINK
WITNESSED COOPERATIONS BIG
PROBLEM.
I THINK THE ITS BAD FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE.
A BAD FOR VICTIMS RIGHTS BAD
FOR.
THE RIGHTS DEFENDANTS I THINK
IT'S BAD FOR EVERYBODY.
WHEN YOU HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID.
TO COME FORWARD AND TESTIFY.
AND I DON'T LIKE TRIAL BY AMBUSH
I THINK IT'S.
OF.
.
AND A RONI ITS WAY TO PRACTICE
LAW BUT LET'S NOT DELUDE
OURSELVES PEOPLE DO IT.
AND SO I THINK THIS PROPOSAL
WILL WILL HELP.
EMIRATE THAT CONCERN AS WELL.
MY QUESTIONS ARE ONE.
AND IS THERE ANY CONTEMPLATED
REMEDY FOR SOMETHING THAT
VIOLATES THIS.
.
WOULD IT BE A MIS TRIAL
SITUATION IF A PROSECUTOR
VIOLATED OR WOULD IT BE. A
SANCTION HERBAL TYPE THING AND
IT'S FINE IF IT'S NOT BUT I
JUST.
CURIOUS AND MY SECOND QUESTION
IS.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DUE IF THIS
PASSES AND IT'S PROBABLY OUTSIDE
THE POLICY OF THE BILL BUT JUST
IN TERMS OF?
INFORMING THE BAR AND
PRACTITIONERS BECAUSE THIS.
IS A PRETTY BIG CHANGE IF THIS
IS SIGNED INTO LAW HOW WE GOING
TO LET.
ATTORNEYS NOW SO THE
PRACTITIONERS ARE NOT.
RUNNING AFOUL OF THE NEW
REQUIREMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
I THINK.
AS WITH ANY.
.
PROVISION AND THE EVIDENCE CODE
OUT COURTS DO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO.
THANK CHAIRMAN ATTORNEY WHO.
WHO VIOLATES A PARTICULARLY IF
THAT'S
NOT INNOCENT?
VIOLATION.
AND SO THEY DO HAVE THOSE TOOLS
ARE AT THE STATE BAR ACTUALLY
THAT SERVICES COULD THAT'S
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AT THE SAME
TIME THEY APPROACH ME. WITH HIS
BILL IDEA THEY ALSO SUBMITTED A
REQUEST TO THE STATE BAR TO
CONSIDER RULE QUIRK.
AND THE STATE BAR IS EVALUATING
AYE DOT SO IT IS THEY THE STATE
BAR MAY ALSO ADOPT ON ITS OWN A
RULE OF PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT SO
THERE WILL BE THAT DUAL. ATTRACT
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT THERE
ARE.
GOOD IT WILL BE ENFORCEABLE AYE
AND.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE STATE BAR IS
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE OF I
BELIEVE I'M CONFIDENT THEY WILL
HELP GET THE WORD OUT SO THAT
ATTORNEYS AT NO.
AND THAT'S THE GOOD.
POINTS MISTER VICE CHAIR WITH
WITH SOMETHING LIKE THIS BECAUSE
IT'S.
OFTENTIMES IN LITIGATION SOME
FACTORS DRAWN TO TRY AND
INFLUENCE A JURY ABOUT A WITNESS
CREDIBILITY. BUT IN THIS CASE
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE EFFECTIVE
BUT IT COULD ALSO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT THAT'S MENTAL FACTS
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
TESTIMONY AND THAT'S WHY. THIS
IS A. VERY GOOD APPROACH
BECAUSE.
THOSE WITNESSES ARE GONNA BE
FEARFUL FOR COMING FORWARD.
IF IMMIGRATION STATUS IS JUST
MENTIONED.
AS A WAY OF INTIMIDATING A
WITNESS THAN OTHER WITNESSES ARE
NOT LIKELY TO COME FORWARD SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE DILEMMA WE
FIND OURSELVES IN IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS.
SYSTEM THAT IS BY NATURE SET UP
TO BE.
CONTROVERSY AND AND AND DRIVEN.
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS KALRA
DIDN'T DISAPPROVE OF THANK
MICHELLE VERY BRIEFLY.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHEN THIS
FLORIDA SOME OF THAT WORK IS A
PUBLIC DEFENDER. OF FOR THAT IN
YEARS I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO WORK.
BUT BOTH.
PUT THE DISK INTERNEES AND AS
WELL AS PUBLIC DEFENDERS TO COME
TO. A RESOLUTION THAT ALLOWED
FOR BOTH TO TO DO THEIR JOB AND
EFFECTIVE MANNER.
I CAN THINK OF A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS WHERE IF.
IMMIGRATION STATUS WOULD HAVE
BEEN ALLOWED TO HAVE BEEN CALLED
INTO QUESTION A LOT OF.
WITNESSES A OF MINE THAT I HAD
IN DEFENSE OF CLIENTS WOULD
HESITATE TO COME FORWARD AS
WITNESSES. AND SO I THINK IT
GOES BOTH WAYS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS LEFT OUT
AS IT SHOULD BE UP AS A RELEVANT
IN THE FAR MAJORITY OF CASES.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU.
ESPECIALLY IN AND IN THESE
TIMES UPPER RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
CIGNA.
TENERGY MAY CLOSE RESPECTFUL
EFFORT AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE'LL TAKE IT UP FOR ABOUT AS
SOON AS WE DO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE MISTER COOPER
.
MONNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
SET THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY NINE WOULD
ALLOW A MINOR WHO IS TWELVE
YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER. MS BEEN A
VICTIM OF IT INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE
THE ABILITY TO CONSENT TO A
MEDICAL CARE. TO SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EVIDENCE EXAMINATION
WITHOUT PARENTAL CONSENT.
CURRENTLY MINORS FOR TWELVE
YEARS OLD.
OUR OLDER KICKING SENT TO
MEDICAL TREATMENT WITHOUT
PARENTAL CONSENT IF THEY'VE BEEN
RAPED OR SEXUALLY ASSAULTED. THE
CANNOT FIT BEEN ABUSED BY
PARTNER.
MANY MINERS IN FEAR OF THEIR
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS FINDING OUT
ABOUT THE ABUSE MAY NOT SEEK
TREATMENT FOR ABUSE FROM A
PARTNER.
THIS BILL WOULD FIX THIS
LOOPHOLE BELONG A MINOR WHO'S
THE VICTIM OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE THE RIGHT TO GET
MEDICAL TREATMENT WITHOUT PERIL
CONSENT.
THIS WOULD ELIMINATE AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF COMPLICATION
OF VICTIMS
OF INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE AND
MAKE IT EASIER FOR MINORS WHO'VE
BEEN ABUSED TO SEEK HELP.
HERE WITH ME TESTS WHERE MEMBERS
OF CAL SAFE.
MICHELLE SEWERS AND HILLY
LARKIN.
OUR SPIFFY I THREE. THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMAN STONE
AND MEMBERS OF.
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MICHELLE SHORES I AM A FORENSIC
NURSE EXAMINER.
I'M HERE AT WITH OF.
I AM ONE OF SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE
REGIONAL LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
THE ASSOCIATION FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT FORENSIC EXAMINERS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO
KNOWN AS KELSEY.
WE REPRESENT ALL OF. OF FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO HAVE WITH ME.
HILLARY LARKIN.
KIM MARKER AND.
JACQUELINE WINTERS HALL.
KELSEY UPSET SPONSORED AB THREE
ONE EIGHT NINE INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN COOPER.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD
WE HAVE FOUND THOUGHT INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE.
THERE IS A AT IDENTIFIED GOT
FORM VICTIMS AGES TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN. THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
INCLUDING STRANGULATION.
CURRENTLY THERE'S A LACK OF
LEGAL CAPACITY FOR THE FOR THIS
VICTIM POPULATION TO CONSENT FOR
MEDICAL CARE OR EVIDENTIARY
EXAMS WITHOUT APPARENT.
IN MY PRACTICE I HAVE FOUND THAT
MINERS DO FEAR COMING FOR WITH
THEIR PARENTS.
WHICH CAN CREATE A DAY JUST
BARRIER TO SERVICES.
AB THREE ONE EIGHT NINE WILL
BRIDGE THAT GAP AND BY ALLOWING
MINORS OVER THE AGE OF TWELVE
THE AUTHORITY TO CONSENT FOR
MEDICAL CARE AN EVIDENTIARY
EXAMS.
A THEY WILL BE ABLE TO GET THE
HELP THEY NEED ALSO E. B. THREE
ONE EIGHT NINE BUT USES THE. GUY
USES THE DEFINITION INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE TO BE MORE
CONSISTENT WITH THE DEFINITION
JEWS BY THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE.
BUT CDC FACT SHEET SHOWS THAT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE NATION OF OUR TWENTY ONE
PERCENT OF FEMALES AND TEN
PERCENT OF MALES HAVE
EXPERIENCED PHYSICAL VIOLENCE.
ADULTS REPORT THAT THEY BE THEY
STARTED A.
EXPERIENCING PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
IN THE HANDS OF INTIMATE PARTNER
AT AGE OF AT THE EARLIEST AGE OF
ELEVEN.
ALSO ONE IN FOUR THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE OF SIXTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF THOSE WILL HAVE A NON FATAL
STRANGULATION.
SO WE REALLY FEEL THAT REMOVING
THAT BARRIER WILL ALLOW.
TEENS TO COME FORWARD AND A
LINE WITH THE SAME.
RIGHTS THAT ARE IN THE FAMILY
CODE FOR TWELVE AND ABOVE.
THE CONSENT.
THANK YOU OUT TAKE TWO MORE
WITNESSES SO NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS HILARY LARKIN.
AND I AM A PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT
I WORK AT HIGHLAND HOSPITAL IN
OAKLAND.
I'M IN MY IN THE CAPACITY OF MY
JOB I WEAR THREE HATS I AM A
SEXUAL ASSAULT EXAMINER I RUN A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE REPORT IN
REFERRAL SERVICE. AND ALSO CHAIR
OF THE DOMESTIC BROWN'S FATALITY
REVIEW TEAM.
I'M.
HIGHLAND HOSPITAL TREATS VICTIMS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT FOURTEEN YEARS
ARE OVER TIME IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS WE CAN CARE FOR FOURTEEN
HUNDRED VICTIMS.
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF THEM ARE
ABOUT FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD THAN THAT'S PRETTY
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
AREA. ABOUT TEN PERCENT OF
THOSE TEENS ARE ASSAULTED BY A
CURRENT OR EXPORT PARTNER SO WE
ARE SEEING THESE TEENS EVERYDAY
IN OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. BUT
NOT IN THE NUMBERS THAT WE WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE THEM.
IN THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WORLD
ABOUT WE SEE ABOUT FIVE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I CASES A WEEK.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE FOURTEEN
SINCE WE'VE BEEN SEEING AT
REPORTING CASES WE'VE SEEN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED CASES.
ONLY TWELVE OF THOSE ARE VICTIMS
BETWEEN TWELVE AND SEVENTEEN WHO
WERE REALLY MISSING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TREAT THESE
VICTIMS.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS WHO
ALSO DON'T UNDERSTAND WHEN TO
WHEN THEY CAN SEND.
PATIENTS TO EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS FOR TREATMENT
ASSESSOR AROUND INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE.
.
THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FATALITY
REVIEW TEAM WHICH I'VE CHAIRED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX HAS.
.
STUDIED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE DEATHS.
I RELATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEVEN OF THOSE WERE MINORS.
AND FOUR OF THOSE WERE KILLED BY
THEIR INTIMATE PARTNERS.
SO WERE SEEN OUR INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE JUSTIN ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
AT A HOMICIDE LEVEL AT A SEXUAL
ASSAULT LEVEL AND THE PHYSICAL
ABUSE LEVEL.
ON THE.
THREE AT AB THREE ONE EIGHT
NINE WOULD MAKE OUR JOBS SIMPLER
IT WOULD GIVE US MORE.
ACCESS TO THESE TEENS AND MAKE
IT SIMPLER FOR A. HOT HIGH
SCHOOL AND SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS REFER PATIENTS TO US TO
GET THE CARE THEY NEED.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT IT WOULD.
SAVE LIVES.
IMPORTANT FOR US
TO REMOVE AS MANY BARRIERS AS
POSSIBLE TO THE WORK WE DO.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE.
I'M JACQUELINE WINNERS HALL FROM
BUTTE COUNTY I'M NOT FRIENDS
IGNORES EXAMINER AND THE SAFE
COORDINATOR AT IN THE MEDICAL
CENTER.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT
MICHELLE AND HILLARY SAID. WILL
ALSO SUPPORT WHAT'S HAPPENING UP
IN THE NORTH COUNTY.
THIS BILL ALSO PUTS INTO
ALIGNMENT.
ADOLESCENTS AGES TWELVE AND UP
NOW HAVE THE RIGHT TO CONSENT TO
ALL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. HIV
TESTING AND TREATMENT.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE DRUG AND
ALCOHOL ADDICTION ISSUES.
THEY ALL HAVE THE RIGHTS FOR
THOSE ISSUES THIS IS THE ISSUE
INNER.
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE ISSUE
IS MISSING FROM THAT PIECE
WEEKEND WHEN THEY COME TO US.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED CURRENTLY TO
CONSENT TO THEIR TREATMENT AND
CARE.
WE CAN'T FUNNEL THEM INTO THE
SERVICES THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
ENTITLED TO.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET PAST THIS
BARRIER OF CONSENT.
THANK YOU BRIGHT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
NAME GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TIM
WALKER IN THE M. PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR THE SEXUAL ASSAULT PROGRAM
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY WE ALSO
SERVE SAN BENITO AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTIES.
WHILE WE ARE NOT DOING THE
FRIENDS EXAMS THAT WILL.
AS SAN DIEGO AND ALAMEDA ARE
DOING WE DO SEE THE INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AND EL
ELEVATING IN OUR SEXUAL ASSAULT
CASES.
I WE DO SEE A LOT OF
STRANGULATION.
ALMOST TWENTY TWO PERCENT OF
OUR CASES NOW INCLUDES
STRANGULATION.
I DON'T HAVE THE DATA FOR SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
CURRENTLY EXTRAPOLATING OUT THE
AGE RANGE OF TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN.
BUT THE INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE IS.
PREVALENT IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
FOR SHORT. I AM AND THEN ALSO
WITH THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
AND SEE SEC PATIENTS.
THE INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
EXISTS THERE AS WELL.
SO WE ARE DEATHLY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE ONE NINE THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SING NONE OF IN THE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SAY NONE SCOOBY MIKLOS AFTER
YOU'VE THINK VERSANT PUTTING
TESTIMONY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL.
TAKE IT UP WE HAVE COR.
SOMERS FRIEDMAN.
BUT WE SEEM TO HAVE A LACK OF
BOTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND AUTHORS WANTING TO PRESENT
BILLS.
SO.
WILL.
WAIT PATIENTLY HOPEFULLY WILL.
GET SOME OF BOTH
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU
READY TO PRESENT.
SO LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR NINETY
SECONDS.
IF THE TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA TRACKS A HIGH RATE OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING DUE TO ITS
STRONG ECONOMY LARGE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IN CLOSE PROXIMITY
TO THE U. S. MEXICO BORDER.
A TWENTY TWELVE STUDY CONDUCTED
BY SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
FOUND THAT THE RATES OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING OF IMMIGRANT WORKERS
IN THE PROPERTY SERVICE INDUSTRY
WERE AMONG THE HIGHEST OF ANY
INDUSTRY.
DESPITE EFFORTS TO CURTAIL ABUSE
AGAINST PROPERTY SERVICE WORKERS
ESPECIALLY JANITORS IS WELL
DOCUMENTED THAT TOO MANY
BUSINESSES PAY ON IMMIGRANT
WORKERS IN THE INDUSTRY. BY
OFFERING THEM LONG HOURS WITH
LITTLE PAY.
EMPLOYERS FURTHER VICTIMIZE
THESE WORKERS BY WITHHOLDING
MANY OF THE RIGHTS THEY DESERVE
AND THEY DO THIS BY MUCH
CLASSIFYING THE WORKERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
DOING SO RESULTS IN THE EMPLOYER
BEING FREE FROM LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS PERTAINED OF WAGE
AND HOUR LAWS ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS AS WELL
STATE AND FEDERAL SAFETY
REGULATIONS.
IT ALSO PREVENTS EMPLOYERS FROM
BEING RESPONSIBLE TO PAY
OVERTIME AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN LABOR
CODE SECTION TWO SEVEN FIVE ZERO
POINT FIVE WAS ENACTED TO ENSURE
THE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE NOT
WAS CLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS.
IT PROVIDES A PRESUMPTION.
OVER EIGHTY YEARS LATER A BEAT
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX WOULD
PROVIDE JANITORS AND OTHER
PROPERTY SERVICE WORKERS THE
SAME PROTECTIONS A PRESUMPTION.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR NINE SIX
IS.
MY WITNESS.
RIGHT.
WITNESS PLEASE GOOD MORNING
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN BILL MURPHY
FROM THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF NANCY O'MALLEY.
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS I'VE
DEVELOPED A SPECIALTY IN
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY CRIMES AND
LABOR TRAFFICKING I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH THE
FINE PEOPLE FROM THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD.
THE EDTA THE DEPARTMENT
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
WE'VE BEEN HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
AND.
COMBATING CASES IN THE CARE HOME
INDUSTRY THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY.
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
BUT THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRIES
YOU ME. IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
IT'S ALL BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
LATE AT NIGHT.
IMAGINE THIS ROOM AT ONE IN THE
MORNING.
THERE NO WITNESSES TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THIS BILL WOULD OPEN UP THIS
INDUSTRY TO ALL THE ENFORCEMENT
AND INSPECTION ACTIVITIES.
OF THOSE STATE AGENCIES I
MENTIONED. AND YOUR LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS OFFICES.
IT WOULD PROTECT THE WORKERS
THAT HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED BY
CASES I WORK ON.
STUDIES MENTIONED.
AND OTHER REPORTS TO THOSE STATE
AGENCIES.
IT MIRRORS WHAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY DONE BY THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
AND.
IT FIXES A SMALL OMISSION.
THERE IS A GREAT FIRST STEP TO
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS REGISTER
THESE JANITORIAL COMPANIES.
BUT THE WAY IT STANDS RIGHT NOW
IS ALL THOSE COMPANIES CAN JUST
SAY.
THEY'RE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
WE DON'T HAVE PAYMENT WEIGHTS WE
DON'T PAY TAXES.
WE DON'T HAVE TO BUY INSURANCE.
AND OF THE INVESTIGATION.
WITH THIS PRESUMPTION IT OPENS
THE DOOR.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THINK MARY CRAZE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS
GOVERNMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ MCLA RESPECT LAST NIGHT
OF.
TAKE IT UP WHEN WE GET A QUORUM
WE STILL HAVE A CORE OF SO STICK
AROUND I AM SICK.
RIGHT ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TWO.
MISTER CHAIR. I'D I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE FIVE
AND SIX OF THE ANALYSIS THEY.
SLAVIN AN INDONESIAN DOMESTIC
WORK ON THEIR HOME FORCING HER
TO. WORK BETWEEN SIXTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN HOURS A DAY WITH NO
PAIN NO DAYS OFF.
THEY BE IS THIS VICTIM BY
RETAINING HER PASSPORT MAKING
HER BELIEVE SHOULD BE PHYSICALLY
HARMED IF YOU DID NOT PERFORM
HER DUTIES.
IN ANOTHER SIMILAR CASE IN
ORANGE COUNTY WOMAN WAS ARRESTED
FOR KEEPING FIVE WOMEN ONE FROM
CANYON FOR FROM THE PHILIPPINES
AS SLAVES FOR HER FAMILY.
I TWENTY FOURTEEN URBAN
INSTITUTE STUDY FOUND THAT MANY
VICTIMS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING
WERE SUBJECT TO A VARIETY OF
PHYSICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
TACTICS MEANT TO CONTROL ENSLAVE
THE VICTIMS INCLUDING THE USE OF
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE.
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE IS THE
PRACTICE OF AN EMPLOYER
WITHHOLDING AND IMMIGRANTS LEGAL
DOCUMENTS FOR PURPOSE OF
MANIPULATING THE EMPLOYEE.
WITH A VAST MAJORITY OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS BEING
IMMIGRANTS IT IS VITAL THE
CALIFORNIA PROTECT THESE WORKERS
BY PREVENTING EMPLOYERS WHO
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO HELPS
PROTECT WORKERS AGAINST THIS
PRACTIE BY PROVIDING A
FRAMEWORK TO HOLD EMPLOYERS
ACCOUNTABLE WHO ENGAGE AND
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE AND
DETERMINING.
A VIOLATION IS A MISDEMEANOR
WITH THE POTENTIAL CIVIL PENALTY
OF UP TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES A WORKERS
BILL OF RIGHTS IN WHICH EMPLOYER
MUST PROVIDE A COPY TO EVERY
WORKER.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY HAVE AS
A WITNESS BEEN SAN DIEGO ADDED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY LARA TANNING
ON BEHALF OF. SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER STUFF
AND SPONSOR OF THIS BILL FIRST
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR CARRYING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
SHE AND OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OR FEARS ADVOCATES FOR VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN GENERAL.
AND.
OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
PROTECTING HUMAN VICTIM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS FOR FOUR
YEARS.
BUT LABOR TRAFFICKING HAS
REMAINED IN THE SHADOWS IT IS
DIFFICULT TO RECOGNIZE AND
ENFORCE.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND ANY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EXCUSE ME BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN. NATIONAL
HOTLINES FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HAVE RECEIVED OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND CALLS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING AND OVER TEN
THOUSAND POTENTIAL CASES OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING. BUT ACCORDING
TO THE TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
POLARIS STUDY. WORLDWIDE FORCED
LABOR IS BELIEVED TO BE MORE
PREVALENT THAN SEX TRAFFICKING.
IT IS UNDER REPORTED HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE THE
VICTIMS ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
OUR LAWS THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
DEPORTATION. AND MAYOR
THREATENED CONSTANTLY WITH
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE DEBT DEBT
SERVITUDE. AND BEING SEPARATED
FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
IN A STUDY AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY OVER THIRTY ONE
PERCENT OF SPANISH SPEAKING
WORKERS HAVE EXPERIENCE AN
INCIDENT MEETING THE DEFINITION
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TRAFFICKING.
IRONICALLY SEVENTY ONE PERCENT
OF LABOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
ENTERED THE UNITED STATES ON
VALID WORK FORCE V. SAYS.
BY THE TIME THEY FINISH THEIR
EMPLOYMENT OR WITHIN A FEW YEARS
SIXTY NINE PERCENT OF THOSE
LABOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS.
HAD NO LONGER A VALID VISA AND
WERE CONSIDERED TO BE A IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
ONE FORM OF CONTROL AS THE
AUTHOR STATED IS WITHHOLDING
THEIR IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS AND
THREATENING THEM WITH
DEPORTATION.
THIS OCCURS NOT ONLY A NAIL
SALONS AND FOOD SERVICES AND IN
JANITORIAL SERVICES AS
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED BUT IN JUST
ABOUT EVERY OTHER. LABOR
SERVICE IN THIS COUNTRY
INCLUDING CONSTRUCTION
AGRICULTURE.
A.
DOCUMENT I EXCUSE ME DOMESTIC
SERVICE SAYS.
IMMIGRANTS AGAIN ARE EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE IN SAN DIEGO ARE
PROSECUTORS HAVE TALKED TO
VICTIMS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING.
WHO'VE HAD THEIR VISAS WITH HELD
THIS PROBLEM IS REAL AND THIS
EXPLOITATION HOUSE TO STOP. AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO SHINES A
LIGHT ON THIS ISSUE. EMPOWERS
VICTIMS BY GIVING THEM VALID
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR LAWS.
AND ALLOWS THEM TO RECOGNIZE THE
TRUE FACTS FROM THE FICTION THAT
THEIR HE HUMAN TRAFFICKERS ARE
EXPOSING THEM TO. THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US I
BELIEVE WE ARE ACCEPTING THEIR.
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WAS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER MAKERS.
I I JUST WANNA THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING.
OF THIS ALONG AND AND THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A VERY.
.
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION AND I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS
TRAINS OFFICE I I'VE BEEN ASKING
FOR YEARS FOR A. BILL DEALING
WITH LABOR TRAFFICKING BECAUSE
WE DO A LOT ON SEX TRAFFICKING
AS WE SHOULD. ON BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT LABOR TRAFFICKING IS
ACTUALLY EIGHT THE LARGER
PROBLEM AND ONE THAT WE NEED TO
START TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
ADDRESS SO. I HOPE WE CAN MOVE
THIS BELFOUR'S NINE RESPECT LAST
NIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK.
RIGHT MISS FRIEDMAN.
GOOD ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY. EIGHT OH TO.
GOOD MORNING MORNING.
MORNING CHAIR STONE A MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF FOR THEIR HELP ON THE
BILL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AS
LAID OUT IN THE ANALYSIS THANK
YOU AB TWENTY EIGHT OR TWO WOULD
REQUIRED INSURER IN COOPERATION
WITH DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES. TO IDENTIFY INSURANCE
CLAIMANTS WHO OH PASTOR CHILD
SUPPORT INTERCEPT THEIR
INSURANCE PAYMENTS AND DIVERT
THAT INCOME TO THE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE CRITICAL
INCOME THEY RELY ON AND THAT TO
WHICH THEY ARE.
THEY ARE ENTITLED MANY FAMILIES
WHO RECEIVE CHILD SUPPORT OFTEN
DEPEND ON THIS INCOME TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. RECENT ESTIMATES FROM
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES SHOWTHEIR
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND. OPEN CHILD
SUPPORT CASES WITH PASSED DUE
BALANCES. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE TOTAL AMOUNT OWED
AND PAST A CHILD SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA WAS SEVENTEEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
OF THE SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION OWED LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA INTERCEPTED ONLY'S
NINETEEN MILLION THROUGH VARIOUS
CHILD SUPPORT INTERCEPT
PROGRAMS.
THROUGH OUR VOLUNTARY INSURANCE
INTERCEPT PROGRAM LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA INTERCEPTED ONLY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
SEVEN OTHER STATES CURRENTLY
OPERATE SUCCESSFUL MANDATORY
INTERCEPT PROGRAMS WHEN TEXAS
FIRST IMPLEMENTED THEIR
STATEWIDE INSURANCE INTERCEPT
PROGRAM IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
THEY SOUGHT INITIAL HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT INCREASE. IN
CHILD SUPPORT COLLECTIONS AND
COLLECTED AROUND SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR ALONE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH TWO IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN WHO DEPEND ON CHILD
SUPPORT AS A SOURCE OF INCOME
RECEIVE WHAT THEY DESERVE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS KATIE AND
HER OF CHILDREN NOW A CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION DEVOTED TO
PROVIDING CHILDREN WITH A VOICE
IN POLICY DISCUSSIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S THE COMMITTEE IN MY NAME
IS KATIE AND ZERO AND I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH
CHILDREN NOW. A LEADING
NONPARTISAN RESEARCH POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
PROMOTING CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY EIGHT OR
TWO.
CHILD SUPPORT IS THAT CRITICAL
INCOME FOR ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
UNFORTUNATELY MOST FAMILIES ARE
NOT RECEIVING ALL OF THE MONEY
THAT THEY ARE OWED. AND AS WE
JUST HEARD IN CALIFORNIA ALONE
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF UNPAID CHILD
SUPPORT IS NEARLY EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S BEEN TWENTY TWO YEARS SINCE
CONGRESS PASSED THE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND WORK
OPPORTUNITY RECONCILIATION ACT
WHICH ALLOWED STATE CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES TO OBTAIN
ACCESS TO INFORMATION ABOUT
ASSETS HELD BY INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND SIXTEEN YEARS.
SINCE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES
CREATED THE CURRENT VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM.
SEVEN OTHER STATES HAVE CREATED
MANDATORY ENSURE PARTICIPATION
PROGRAMS HOWEVER CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRAM IS STILL VOLUNTARY WITH
LESS THAN TWENTY PERCENT OF
INSURERS PARTICIPATING.
A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES OF
INSURANCE MATCH SUCCESS STORIES
FROM THE FEDERAL OFFICE OF CHILD
SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT INCLUDE
FIFTY TWO. THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH PAID
ALMOST HALF OF THE ARREARS TO A
FAMILY WHO HAD NOT RECEIVED A
PAYMENT IN ELEVEN YEARS.
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE DOLLARS PAID
TO CUSTODIAL DIED IN A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER WHO HAD NOT
RECEIVED A PAYMENT IN THREE
YEARS.
AS YOU CAN PROBABLY IMAGINE IN
CASES LIKE THIS WHERE NON
CUSTODIAL PISSED DIDN'T PARENTS
ARE NON COMPLIANT WITH THEIR
SUPPORT. INSURANCE INTERCEPTS
CAN PROVIDE A CRUCIAL LIFELINE
TO FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO
MAINTAIN FINANCIAL STABILITY.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH TWO WOULD
REQUIRE INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN A LONG
ESTABLISHED INTERCEPT PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE COLLECTION
OF OVERDUE CHILD SUPPORT AND
HELP IMPROVE THE QUALITY. OF
LIFE FOR CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT OF REALITY FOR
THE CHILDREN IN THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THINKING.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROBERT HERALDICALLY
COMMISSIONER FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE WHERE THE SPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE LIKE TO THANK AGAIN
THE AUTHOR AND HER FANTASTIC
STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK. AS WELL
AS YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR A
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS ON THIS I'M
AS BOTH THE AUTHOR AND THE LEAD
WITNESS MENTIONED SEVEN STATES
HAVE THIS. ITEM WE WOULD JUST
URGE THAT AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. WE LOOK TO GET AS MANY
INSURANCE LINES AS POSSIBLE AS
REASONABLY POSSIBLE INTO THIS.
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO MANY OF THE
OTHER SEVEN STATES AND NOT JUST
LIFE BUT ALSO PROPERTY CASUALTY
LINES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
CHAIR MEMBER ASPECT OF THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION
OUT WE LIKE FIRST LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
TO HELP CLARIFY SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL. AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
FOR HER COMMITMENT TO WORK
CONTINUE WORKING WITH US AS WE
PROCEED ON THE SPELL. THAT BACK
CLARIFY SOME ADDITIONAL AFFECTS
THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
SHRIEKING AT THE ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE AUTHOR STAFF.
AND WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY
THE PROGRESS BEING MADE ON THE
FLOOR TO CONTINUE THEIR WORK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CUNNINGHAM.
I WOULD. JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL.
I JUST HAD ONE QUICK TECHNICAL
QUESTION ABOUT THE IMMUNITY
PROVISIONS. ARE THEY. WHAT WHAT
ARE THEY IN THE BILL CURRENTLY
IN?
DO YOU FORESEE ANY CHANGING
THEIR STRIPPING AWAY OF THE
IMMUNITY I THINK. REASON*
SEEMS LIKE AN IMPORTANT.
FEATURE OF THE BILL TO MAKE THE
WHOLE SYSTEM WORK WELL.
RIGHT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT INSURANCE
COMPANIES AREN'T HELD LIABLE.
THROUGH AN ERROR BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF AN INSURANCE
COMPANY ACTS AS A PARTY IS A. IN
BAD FAITH THAT THERE IS A WAY TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE GOAL OF THE
INDIAN COMMUNITY CLAUSE IN THE
IN THE BILL.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CNN IS THREE MILLION RECORDS.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR A
LOT OF KIDS OUT THERE AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL TAKE
UP.
ASSUMING WE GET A QUORUM.
GARCIA.
STYX'S TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A.
B. TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES.
PROUD TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX.
THIS BILL IS A PROCEDURAL
MEASURE THAT WOULD CREATE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FUND INTO
WHICH THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
MAY DEPOSIT MONEY TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR THE NEWLY CREATED
BUREAU OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
YOU GAVE YOUR OF MISSION IS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE IN COMMUNITIES
THAT IN VERY DISPROPORTIONATE
SHARE ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION.
TO INVESTIGATION ENFORCEMENT OF
VIOLATIONS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS.
THE COMMUNITIES OFTEN LACK THE
RESOURCES TO INVESTIGATE OR
LITIGATE CASES THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS AND IMPROVE THEIR
HEALTH.
JUSTICE SHOULD NOT BE RESERVED
FOR COMMUNITIES WHO CAN AFFORD
THE TO INVESTIGATE AND LITIGATE
PARTIES.
THAT BREAK THE LAW BY STOP
MOTION SUPPORTING THE WORK OF
THE EPA BUREAU WE ARE TALKING.
TAKING THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS
ASSIST IN THESE COMMUNITIES WHO
OTHERWISE SUFFER POOR HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOMES THEY'RE
MUCH MORE COSTLY TO STATE IF
LEFT ON. ADDRESSED ONE THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL THEM HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT THAT WITH
ME.
MARIO THE BERNARDO WHO IS THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO TESTIFY.
WE HAVE. THANK YOU.
WITH THIS PLACE MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARIO DIBERNARDO AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL HOBBY ARE BUT SARAH
WHO'S PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
I DON'T LIKE TO THINK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR HIS
THOROUGH IN AND FAIR ANALYSIS OF
THE BILL.
THE BILL WOULD CREATE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FUND WHERE
FUNDS CAN BE DEPOSITED TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND
UP FOR INVESTIGATIONS AND
LITIGATION WORK CONDUCTED BY
DOJ'S RECENTLY ESTABLISHED.
BUREAU IN FROM OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
THE HARSH REALITY IS THAT SOME
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BEAR THE
BRUNT OF POLLUTION. FROM
INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT POORLY
AND USE DECISIONS AND
TRANSPORTATION.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES REQUIRES ARE FOCUSED
ATTENTION.
THAT'S WHY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CREATED THE BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
BJ BUREAU WILL HELP PROTECT
PEOPLE COMMUNITIES THAT INTO OUR
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION. THROUGH
INVESTIGATION ENFORCEMENT OF
VIOLATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX SIMPLY
ESTABLISHES A SPECIAL FUND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FUND THAT
IT WOULD UP THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO TO BUY.
EXCUSE ME TO DEPOSIT FUNDS.
SUCH AS SETTLEMENT AND PENALTY
MONIES FROM CASES
THE PURPOSE OF PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO THE E. J.
BUREAU.
JUST TO CLARIFY SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL CONFUSION.
.
THAT.
HAS COME UP WITH THIS BILL THE
FUND IS NOT INTENDED TO CREATE A
BOUNTY SYSTEM WHERE THE AG TAKES
CASES TO OBTAIN REVENUES TO FUND
THE BUREAU.
THAT WOULD NOT BE SUSTAINABLE
SOURCE OF REVENUE TO SUPPORT THE
BUREAU.
ESPECIALLY SINCE MANY OF THE J.
CASES WILL FOCUS ON INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF.
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
SEEKING A BUDGET REQUEST ENSURE
THE BUREAU SUPPORTED BY GENERAL
FUNDS WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE OPPOSITIONS.
POINT OF VIEW HIGH LATE
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
ALSO THE J. BUREAUS NOT
RESTRAINED BY THE CALAVERAS
SCREENS DEFINITION OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THE
BUREAU CAN TAKE ON CASES
INVOLVING COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITIES
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOUR I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AND OF
US BECAUSE WE ARE BEHALF A
CALIFORNIA RUNS TO SO I
ANSWERING. IN GRADE SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL FOR THE REASONS STATED
BUT ALSO I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL. AND HEALTH
COALITION AND ALSO I AM ASIA
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SCORES HERE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD SINCE I
SET A BUDGET OF FIVE I DID HAVE
THE CHANCE TO TALK TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ABOUT. THIS
BUREAU THAT HE'S CREATING AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU WE
NEED TO FIND THAT AND FUNDED
THROUGH A BUDGET ASK WHICH I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THAT.
THEY ASK THAT YOU HAVE DONE BUT.
THIS ALSO MAKES THAT STICK
TO CREATE A FUND ALLOW FOR SOME.
FLEXIBILITY AND ENSURE THAT OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE IN
FACT HAVING THEIR ISSUES BEING
ADDRESSED AS WE TRIED SOLVE SOME
OF OUR MORE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
YOU FOR.
BRINGING THE SWORD NICKY WAS
CHAIR.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SING NONE MISTER GARCIA YOU MAY
CLOSE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
RESPECT RESPIRABLE. THANK YOU
SIR.
WE WILL DO THAT HOPEFULLY
SOMETIME TODAY
.
SINCE.
WE'RE GONNA BE SITTING HERE FOR
IT LOOKS LIKE A LITTLE BIT WHEN
WE TAKE A RECESS UNTIL TEN
THIRTY. GIVE THE SERGEANTS A
CHANCE TO REACH OUT SEE IF WE
GET SOME AUTHORS AND THE REST
THE COMMITTEE HERE. SO WE CAN
START MOVING SOME OF THESE BILLS
ALONG.
THOSE THAT ARE JUST SITTING HERE
TWIDDLING MEMBERS PLEASE BE BACK
AT TEN THIRTY THAT YOU CAN GET
OTHER MEMBERS HERE AND FINISH
OUR BUSINESS SO WE'LL TAKE A
FIFTEEN MINUTE RECESS.
THANK YOU
NOW ARE YOU READY PRESENT.
AND SINCE LAST.
I WE WILL COME BACK TO ORDER
AFTER A BRIEF RECESS.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR WHO.
TWO AUTHORS INTO MEMBERS THE
COMING HERE.
FABULOUS.
RIGHT MISTER TO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE. YOUR.
A PATIENTS I KNOW THIS IS A BUSY
DAY HAVE GOT FOR BILLS TO
PRESENT AND THREE COMMITTEES
MEETING SIMULTANEOUSLY SO. I
UNDERSTAND WE'LL TRY TO GIVE AS
MUCH LATITUDE AS WE CAN BUT.
WE CAN GET THAT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BACK AS WELL WE WE HAVE
YET EVEN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
BUT LET ME IF I COULD START BY
PRESENTING.
AB TWENTY ONE P. FIVE THAT'S
ALRIGHT NUMBER THREE PLEASE
GREAT THANK YOU. UP COLLEAGUES
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
AN INDIVIDUAL IN LITIGATION TO
PROCEED ANONYMOUSLY AFTER COURT
CONSIDERS A NUMBER OF RELEVANT
FACTORS.
UNLIKE OTHER STATES THAT DO HAVE
STANDARDS FOR PLAINTIFFS TO
PURSUE LITIGATION WITH A
PSEUDONYM CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
HAVE SUCH A STANDARD.
THERE MANY CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
WHICH THIS MAY BE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY FOR OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
TO PROTECT PRIVACY AND SENSITIVE
AND HIGHLY PERSONAL MATTERS WHEN
THERE'S A RISK OF RETALIATORY
PHYSICAL HARM. OR DURING THIS
TIME IN HISTORY WHEN A PLAINTIFF
LEGITIMATELY FEARS ARE REVEALING
ONE'S IDENTITY COULD SUBJECT HIM
OR HERSELF TO DEPORTATION.
GIVEN THE CURRENT NATIONAL
CLIMATE MANY IMMIGRANTS ARE
EXTREMELY HESITANT TO APPEAR IN
COURT OR OTHERWISE TAKE PART IN
PROCEEDINGS.
BECAUSE OF THIS FEAR IMMIGRANTS
WOULD OTHERWISE TESTIFIES
WITNESSES IN CRIME OR PURSUE
LEGAL ACTION.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY RELEVANT
ONE MINOR PLAINTIFFS NEED TO
HAVE AN APPOINTED GUARDIAN AD
LITEM BUT THEIR PARENTS ARE NOT
DOCUMENTED.
OUR BILL WOULD REQUIRE A COURT
TO CONTINUE CONSIDER A NUMBER OF
FACTORS IN DETERMINING THE NEED
FOR ANONYMITY. AND ANOTHER PARTY
COULD CHALLENGE THE USE OF A
PSEUDONYM. AYE AND OF A COURT
ORDER IS THE IDENTIFICATION OF
THAT LIVE AGAIN THAT LITIGANT
COULD DISMISS CLAIMS WITHOUT
PREJUDICE.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSOR
MODIFYING AND TURN IT OVER TO
MULL THIS WITNESS.
A QUICK WARNING WHICH AIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JANET SUNNY BUT THEN I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY FROM ALL
LEFT. THE MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL
DEFENSE AND EDUCATIONAL FUND
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE
ADDRESSES A SIGNIFICANT GAP IN
STATE LAW ITEM WHERE WE REALLY
DO NOT HAVE A PROCESS FOR FOLKS
WHO DO WATER. EITHER.
GO THROUGH CIVIL LITIGATION
WITH A PSEUDONYM OR FICTITIOUS
NAME. AND WHAT MOST COURTS DOING
CALIFORNIA AS THEY DO FOLLOW THE
FEDERAL RULE HOWEVER OUR
LITIGATORS HAVE SEEN
INCONSISTENT RESULTS ESPECIALLY
WITH OUR CLIENTS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IT SEEMS THAT WE
HAVE A HARDER TIME. TRYING TO
TRYING TO CONVINCE JUDGES Y.
SOMEONE WAS UNDOCUMENTED MAY
WANT TO PROCEED WITH A
PSEUDONYM.
FOR ME WANT TO PROCEED WITH A
FICTITIOUS NAME AND SOMEOF THE
RESULT.
WE ARE WE WHAT ARE YOU DOING
THIS BILL TO PROVIDE THE STATE
WITH SOME MORE UNIFORMITY AND TO
HOPEFULLY GET MORE CONSISTENT
RESULTS BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THAT
OTHER VULNERABLE. POPULATIONS
OUTSIDE OF JUST IMMIGRANTS.
FOLKS WHO MAY FEAR.
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL HARM SOMEONE
WHO IS A SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIM
SOMEONE WHO'S A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIM. I'M WOULD BE
ABLE TO PROCEED OUT UNDER A
FICTITIOUS NAME OR A PSEUDONYM
AND I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU A
FEW EXAMPLES OF SOME OF THE
CASES WHERE.
MODIFIES BEEN UNABLE TO PURSUE
LITIGATION BECAUSE OF OUR
CLIENTS BEING TOO AT BEING
AFRAID TO EXPOSE THE TO
IDENTITY.
SO IN A DHAKA EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION CASE WE HAD A
POTENTIAL CLIENT WHO ULTIMATELY
DECLINED TO BECOME A PLAINTIFF
BECAUSE HE REALLY FELT.
AFRAID OF HAVING IS TO IDENTITY
BEING EXPOSED ONE BECAUSE OF
MAYBE FUTURE. THEN ABILITY TO
SECURE FUTURE EMPLOYMENT BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY BECAUSE HE DID
NOT ONE X. EXPOSE HIS FAMILY AS
UNDOCUMENTED AND EXPOSE HIS
PARENTS AS WELL. IN AN EDUCATION
DISCRIMINATION CASE WE HAD A
CHILD WHO WAS BEING FORCED TO
TAKE LANGUAGE CLASSES THAT I'M
HE DIDN'T NEED IT BUT AS PARENTS
WERE TOO AFRAID. TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE CASE BECAUSE OF THEIR
UNDOCUMENTED STATUS AND THEN
LASTLY IN A GUARDIAN AD LITEM
CASE ITEM WE FILED A SUIT ON
BEHALF OF IN AND OUT OF AN
ANONYMOUS MOTHER. AND HER THREE
CHILDREN BUT THE COURT REJECTED
THE MOMS ADAM GUARDIANSHIP
REQUEST BECAUSE YOU DO NOT USE
OUR CHIU NAME. SO WE CANNOT
BRING A MOTION TO FILE THE
CARDING GUARDIANSHIP
APPLICATIONS UNDER SEAL.
AND IN ORDER TO DO SO YOU YOU
BASICALLY HAVE TO SERVE THE
DEFENDANT'S.
AND SO FORTUNATELY THAT KEEPS
WE WERE ABLE TO GET AN A AN
EMERGENCY EX PARTE REQUEST.
A FILE THESE APPLICATIONS UNDER
SEAL BUT THE WHOLE PROCESS.
BECAUSE CONSIDERABLE A
CONSIDERABLE DELAY TO FOUND THE
PROTECTION OF THESE CLAIMS.
AT BECAUSE THIS BILL PRETTY
CLOSELY MIRRORS THE FEDERAL RULE
AND AND DEFINITELY DOES HAVE A
DID DELINEATES A CLEAR PROCESS
WE THINK IT'S. IT'S IT'S JUST A
MUCH NEEDED BILL GIVEN THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION TARGETING
COURTHOUSES IT'S NOT.
TOO HARD TO UNDERSTAND THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE JUST UNDER
CONSTANT FEAR RIGHT NOW AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS OUT WE URGE
AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
ANYONE IN BETWEEN.
MORNING TERRY MEMBERS TAMPON FOR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
WHEN WE REVIEWED THE BILL WE
HAD SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
INTRODUCED.
A VERSION OF THE LEGISLATION
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE NEW
DIRECTION IN THE. CURRENT
IMPRINT VERSION THE BILL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR SPONSOR.
AT IN PUBLIC IT'S THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM E. WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE TO WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INTRODUCED VERSION OF THE
BILL.
AND I'M MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE.
RECENTLY AMENDED VERSION.
UP WE WE DO STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH TO RESPECT THAT WE
SHARED WITH THE AUTHOR AND A
WITH YOUR STAFF.
PRIMARILY DEALING IN THE AREA
WITH ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IS PROPERLY BALANCED.
IN THE PROCESS OF THE COURT
MAKING THE DETERMINATION HERE.
I'M AS WELL AS TIGHTENING UP.
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE SO THAT
IT CANNOT BE ABUSED
BY THOSE THAT WISH TO MASK IN
AND SEEK TO TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF THIS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
ON THAT IN AND THE BILL'S
SPONSORS AS WELL AS YOUR STAFF.
AND WE HAVE NO POSITION AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU.
ANY ANY ACTUAL OPPOSITION.
NONE WE'VE MOVED OPPOSITION TO.
MIDDLE ROAD SO.
THAT'S GOOD.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE ARE QUORUM AT.
SO I CAN THINK OF OCEAN.
ALRIGHT.
DO YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU LET
ME HAVE JUST FIRST STEP THANK
SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT JUST
SPOKE OUT RAISING THEIR CONCERNS
AND WE CERTAINLY.
LOOK FOR TO ENGAGE WITH THEM
AND AND OUR INTENT IS NOT FOR
EXAMPLE TO PREVENT.
NEWSPAPERS FROM THE TABLE TO
ADEQUATELY COVER CASES AND AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WHAT TO REGION
GOOD RESOLUTION ON THAT ADJUST
ALSO MENTION ONE. HISTORICAL
POINT WHICH IS.
POTENTIALLY THE MOST.
FAMOUS CONSTITUTIONAL CASES THE
ROE V. WADE CASE AND JANE ROE
WAS A PSEUDONYM FOR A WOMAN WHO
DID NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE AT THE
TIME THE CASE WAS BROUGHT. ON IN
PROTECTING HER CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO CHOOSE ARM AND I THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE.
AN ADEQUATE STANDARD.
THAT ADDRESSES.
AGAIN THE NEEDS FOR PRIVACY AYE
IN IMPORTANT CIRCUMSTANCES SO
OUT WITH THAT.
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT THIS IS A
BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR REAL
TRUE ACCESS TO THE COURTS AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL AND RESPECT WE
ASK FOR SUPPORT THE RIGHT TIME.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU LET ME FIRST START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I ANY STATE THAT THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE
WOULD ADDRESS IMBALANCES IN THE
CURRENT TENANT NOTICE AND
EVICTION PROCESS WHICH IS
STACKED AGAINST TENANTS AT THIS
TIME.
I THINK EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS AWARE THAT WE'RE
NOT ONLY EXPERIENCING IN
CALIFORNIA THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE HISTORY. BUT
WE ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING A
TENANT CRISIS AND AN EVICTION
CRISIS
WITH THE HIGHEST RENTS IN THE
COUNTRY WITNESS STATE THAT IS.
FORTY SIX PERCENT RUNNERS WERE
ONE THIRD OF ALL RUNNERS ARE
PAIN OVER HALF OF THEIR INCOME
ON RENTS.
WERE SEEN EVICTIONS IN
DISPLACEMENT WHICH HAS LED IN
PART TO THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN OUR STATE.
ACCORDING TO RECENT DATA. WE'VE
SEEN THIS PAST YEAR FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND EVICTION FILINGS
LEADING TO AN AVERAGE OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN EVICTIONS A
DAY. FORTY ONE THOUSAND OF
ACTIONS TOTAL.
IF THOSE FORTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO WERE ADDICTED THIS
PAST YEAR COMPRISED CITY. THE
CITY OF OBJECTIONS WOULD BE
LARGER THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE CITIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
HOPEFULLY THE IMPACT OF
ADDICTIONS IS OBVIOUS BUT.
HEALTH
ON EDUCATION ON COMMUNITY
INSTABILITY.
AND EVICTION PLACES A MARK ON A
PERSON'S RECORD AND CREDIT SCORE
BARS THAT PERSON FROM MOVING
INTO A GOOD HOUSE IN A SAFE
NEIGHBORHOOD. PREVENTS THE
PERSON FROM MOVING INTO PUBLIC
HOUSING.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO PREVENT
AVOIDABLE INFECTIONS WITH
REASONABLE TIME FOR TENANTS TO
RESPOND TO MA'AM OUR FILINGS
THREE THREE WAYS FIRST BY
EXTENDING THE TIME TENANTS HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH THE TERM OF THE
LEASE.
TODAY A TENANT ONLY HAS
THREE DAYS THREE DAYS. ARE TO
PAY LAKE RENT OR QUIT.
IF
AND OF SERVED ON A FRIDAY THAT
LEAVES ATTENDED UNTIL MONDAY TO
ACCESS BANKS ARE CLOSED OVER
WEEKEND. AND HOPEFULLY YOU'RE
NOT SERVE BEFORE HOLIDAY.
CALIFORNIA IS IN A MINORITY OF
STATES WITH ONLY A THREE DAY
NOTICE.
RELATED TO NOT PAIN RENTS A
MAJORITY OF STATES HAVE A THREE
OF A NOTICE PERIOD OF FIVE.
THIRTY DAYS WITH MOST FALLING%
BETWEEN SEVEN AND FOURTEEN DAYS
HERE IN THIS BILL WE PROPOSE
TEN.
SECONDLY THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND
THE TIME TENANTS HAVE TO RESPOND
TO AN EVICTION LAWSUIT.
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA YOU ONLY
HAVE FIVE DAYS
WHICH MEANS THAT IF YOUR SERVED
ON THE THURSDAY BEFORE A LONG
WEEKEND YOU'RE IN TROUBLE.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BASICALLY THE
DAY A DAY AND A HALF OF A
BUSINESS TO FIND A LAWYER
PREPARE YOUR ANSWER TRAVEL TO
THE COURTHOUSE.
AND I LIKE TO POINT OUT IN MOST
CIVIL CASES YOU OFTEN HAVE
THIRTY DAYS.
PREPARE YOUR FIRST ANSWER THIS
BILL PROPOSES A FOURTEEN DAY
TIMELINE FOR RESPONSE.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES OTHER
CHANGES TO
FRIEND EVICTION CASES WITH
LEGITIMATE DEFENSES FOR EXAMPLE
TO REQUIRE THAT A NOTICE TO QUIT
IS SENT THAT IS CENTRAL
LANDLORDS CLEAR.
TO ENSURE ALSO THE SUMMONS ARE
PROPERLY SERVED EXCEPT.
NOW WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK
OUR SPONSORS CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FUND AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER AND FROM THE LEGAL
SERVICES OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
STONE HERE CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHIU HERE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
SO WE DO HAVE A CORE. FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BRUCE.
I'M ALEXANDER HUNTING WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE'RE CO SPONSORING
THIS BILL TOGETHER WITH THE CRLA
FOUNDATION.
ELECTED THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOR AUTHORING AB TWENTY
THIRD.
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE.
AGAINST THE BACKDROP OF
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS RISING RENTS AND
INCREASING HOMELESSNESS IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE DO WHAT WE CAN
TO PREVENT AVOIDABLE INFECTIONS.
THAT CAN BE RESOLVED WITHOUT
DISPLACING TENANTS FROM THEIR
HOMES.
THIS BILL TAKES MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT TENANTS ARE
PROTECTED IN PRACTICALLY
ADDRESSING ISSUES WITH THEIR
LANDLORDS HAVE A MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLY WITH
NOTICES TO PAY RENT FOR SECURE A
BREACH OF POLICE AND KNOW HOW TO
DO SO.
AND ARE ABLE TO PRESENT THEIR
DEFENSE IS ONE EVICTION CASES
ARE FILED AGAINST THEM IN COURT.
LAST FISCAL YEAR ALMOST FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS HAD
UNLAWFUL DETAINER CASES FILED
AGAINST THEM IN JUST THE LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT SYSTEM.
AND THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THOSE
THAT MAY HAVE.
MOVED OUT AFTER RECEIVING AN
EVICTION NOTICE BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T COMPLY WITH THEM THE
THREE DAYS.
CALIFORNIA'S AMONG THE STATES
WITH THE SHORTEST NOTICE PERIODS
FOR EVICTIONS AND LEGAL AID
PROGRAMS WE WORK WITH ARE
OVERWHELMED BY CLIENTS. WERE
FORCED OUT OF THEIR HOMES NOT BY
THEIR UNDERLYING CIRCUMSTANCES
BUT BUT BY THESE TYPE TIME LINES
UP TO COMPLY WITH NOTICES AND TO
FILE THEIR ANSWERS IN COURT.
DESPITE HAVING STRONG CASES THE
ABILITY TO PAY THE RENT THAT
LANDLORDS ARE DEMANDING OR TO
FIX A BREACH OF THE LEAST IF
GIVEN A FEW MORE DAYS THESE
TENANTS ARE LEFT WITHOUT
RECOURSE AND OFTEN END UP
HOMELESS.
EXISTING LAW GIVES TENANTS IN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE THE
ISSUES THAT LEAD TO EVICTIONS.
AND AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE
MAKES THAT OPPORTUNITY
MEANINGFUL.
IT GIVES TENANTS A REASONABLE
TIME TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE WITH A
PAYCHECK OR GOVERNMENT BENEFITS
OR TO SEEK HELP IN ADDRESSING A
BREACH OF THEIR LEASE.
AND ENSURES THAT ALL PARTIES CAN
PRESENT THEIR EVIDENCE AND
ARGUMENTS.
DURING THE COURT PROCESS.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KAREN
CONCERT I AM AN ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL SERVICES AND I THINK
CALIFORNIA ALSO KNOWN AS
LESNICK.
WE ARE THE LEGAL AID AGENCY FOR
TWENTY THREE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES FROM SACRAMENTO TO THE
OREGON BORDER.
WE ASSESS LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH A WIDE
RANGE OF CIVIL LEGAL ISSUES BUT
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE OUR CLIENTS
CONTACT US ABOUT. THROUGHOUT OUR
TWENTY THREE COUNTY SERVICE AREA
IS HOUSING.
WE ASSIST THOUSANDS OF TENANTS
FACING EVICTION EVERY YEAR.
OUR OFFICE THE SAYS MANY TENANTS
WHO ARE HARMED BY THESE SHORT
TIME PERIODS IN WHICH THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO CURING ALLEGE LEASE
VIOLATION. OR RESPOND TO AN
EVICTION ACTION IN COURT.
EVERY WEEK WE SEE CLIENTS WHO
HAVE REACHED OUR OFFICE TOO LATE
TO FILE AN ANSWER IN AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTION. BECAUSE THERE
FIVE DAYS TO RESPOND TO A
SUMMONS HAS PASSED.
A DEFAULT JUDGMENT HAS BEEN
ENTERED AND THEY HAVE LOST THE
CHANCE TO DEFEND THEMSELVES IN
COURT.
RIGHT NOW IS IF A PERSON HAS
SERVED WITH A SUMMONS ON A
WEDNESDAY THEIR ANSWER IS DUE
MONDAY. THAT GIVES THEM THREE
BUSINESS DAYS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS NEEDED TO RESPOND WHERE IN
THE COMMUNITY THEY CAN GO TO FOR
HELP. HOW TO ACTUALLY GET THERE?
AND THEN TO GET TO COURT TO FILE
AN ANSWER.
MANY CLIENTS IN THE MORE RURAL
PARTS OF OUR SERVICE AREAS.
HAVE TO FILE THEIR ANSWER IN
PERSON AT THE COURTHOUSE AND PAY
LARGE FEES WHEN THEY CANNOT
AFFORD THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
FILED BY FAX.
THEY MAY LIVE ONE TO TWO HOURS
AWAY FROM COURT. AND OFTEN LACK
ACCESS TO RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION OUR ELDERLY
DISABLED AND CANNOT MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO GET TO COURT
WITHIN THE SHORT FIVE DAY
PERIOD.
GIVING THESE TENANTS MORE TIME
TO RESPOND TO A SUMMONS WILL
MEAN THAT MORE TENANTS WHO HAVE
MERITORIOUS DEFENSES WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES IN COURT. REMAIN
HOUSE AND AVOID HOMELESSNESS.
CURRENTLY AT OUR OFFICE IN
SACRAMENTO HAS THREE CLIENTS
EACH WITH A DIFFERENT LANDLORDS
WHO EACH RECEIVED THREE DAY
NOTICES TO PAY RATHER QUIT AND
WERE ABLE TO COME UP WITH THE
FULL AMOUNT OF RENT. PROSPER IN
THE NOTICE PLUS LATE FEES
SHORTLY OUTSIDE OF THE THREE DAY
TIME.
WHEN EACH DIFFERENT CLIENT
ATTEMPTED TO PAY THEIR DIFFERENT
LANDLORDS THEIR RENT WAS REFUSED
NOT A PIECE OF FICTION. AND THE
VERY REAL POSSIBILITY OF
BECOMING HOMELESS.
FURTHER WE HAVE A CURRENT CASE
IN THE SACRAMENTO OFFICE WITH A
CLIENT WHO IS ELDERLY AND
DISABLED. AND A VETERAN.
WHO WAS HOSPITALIZED WHEN HIS
LANDLORD SERVE TEN THE THREE DAY
NOTICE TO PAY RENT ARMY ABOUT?
WHEN HE WAS DISCHARGED FROM THE
HOSPITAL HE FOUND THE NOTICE IT
WAS OUTSIDE OF THE THREE DAYS
BUT HE ATTEMPTED TO PAY HIS FULL
AMOUNT OF RENT DEMANDED IN THE
NOTICE.
HIS LANDLORD REFUSED TO ACCEPT
THE RENT. AND IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE EVICTION ACTION.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE EXAMPLES ARE
NOT THE EXCEPTION THE SITUATIONS
ARE COMMON IN. OUR CLIENTS WHEN
THEY GET BEHIND ON RENT.
IT'S USUALLY BECAUSE SOME OF
THAT HAPPENED IN THEIR LIFE SUCH
AS THE HOSPITALIZATION AND
EXPENSE OR JOB LOSS WITH ONLY
THREE DAYS TO CURE. AN ALLEGED
LEASE VIOLATION MANY YOU'RE
UNABLE TO DO SO WE HAVE NO
DOUBT.
THAT EXTENDING THE TIME FOR
WHICH A TENANT CAN CURE LEASE
VIOLATION SUCH AS GETTING CAUGHT
UP IN RED WILL MEAN MORE TENANTS
WILL BE ABLE TO PAY THEIR
LANDLORDS REMAIN HOUSE AND AVOID
HOMELESSNESS COMMITTEE NEED TO
TO WRAP UP PLEASE. AND THINK
OKAY THANK YOU. THAT'S WHAT.
BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIAN TO
CAST ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION PLEASED TO COSPONSOR.
THIS BILL AND FOR ALL THE
REASONS ARTICULATED BY THE THREE
PRIOR SPEAKERS WE WOULD URGE IN
ABOUT.
IF YOU.
ANYONE.
ELSE IN SUPPORT.
COME FORWARD AND JUST GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE
I S. I'D LOVE TO REGISTER MY
SUPPORT.
JONAH STRAUSS OAKLAND WAREHOUSE
COALITION.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MR CHIU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THINKING
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING
IT AND IT IS VERY IMPORTANT AS
AN EX AYE WERE WHERE DON'T
TESTIMONY THIS POINT FUNDS ARE
JUST TAKING FOLKS WHO WERE.
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AND
SUPPORTERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NEW WELLS.
JERRY MEMBERS THEN POEM FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL WE HAVE
REQUESTED A DELAYED OPERATIVE
DATE AMENDMENT TO ALLOW US TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY RULE INFORMED
CHANGES.
AND CONSIDER THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED IF THE BILL IS ENACTED
AND AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
AUTHOR AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
AND SPONSORS ON THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
MORNING GOOD MORNING.
I'M WOULD BE PROUD WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE AS A PRACTICING
ATTORNEY BEFORE COMING TO SEE A.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS DO NOT LIKE TO TERMINATE
A TENDENCY OR PROCEED WITH
EVICTIONS. IT'S EXPENSIVE AND
IT'S TIME CONSUMING. AND
PROPERTY OWNERS WOULD MUCH
RATHER WORK WITH TENANTS IN THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CASES.
THIS BILL WILL ADD WEEKS UP
FRONT TO THE ADDICTION PROCESS.
AND PROVIDE TENANTS WITH WEEKS
OF FREE RENT OUT THE FRONT AND.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE MORE
THAN TRIPLED THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT TENANTS HAVE TO CURE THEIR
NON PAYMENT OF RENT OR OTHER
RELEASE BREACHES.
INCLUDING FOR RENT AFTER IT'S
ALREADY PASSED DO.
FOR THE MAJORITY OF LANDLORDS
WHO ALREADY PROVIDE AGREES
PERIOD THIS WILL NOW MEAN THAT
THEY HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THE
MIDDLE OF THE MONTH.
TO GET THERE RENT OR TO BEGIN
THE EVICTION PROCESS OF THE REC
ROOM REMAINS UNPAID.
THIS BILL WILL PUT UNLAWFUL
DETAINER CASES ON PAR WITH ALL
OTHER CIVIL CASES IN THE STATE.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
THIS BILL DOESN'T JUST ADDRESS
NON PAYMENT ALSO ADDRESSES
SITUATIONS WHERE THE TIME HAS
ENGAGED IN NEW SENSE CREATED A
NEW SENSE OR ENGAGED IN A LEAVE
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY. AS WE HEARD
EARLIER ON MISTER SANTIAGO'S
BILL ARE RELATED TO THE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER IS FOR CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. THESE ARE PROBLEMS
THAT COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE
STRUGGLE WITH AND IT HARMS THE
OTHER TENANTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
WON THE ELECTION THE AFFECTION
PROCESS IS DELAYED.
SMALL MOM AND POP LANDLORDS TO
RELY ON THE RENT TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGE UTILITIES INSURANCE AND
TAX BILLS.
SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO GO
MONTHS ON END WITHOUT A RENT
PAYMENT.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL PREVENTS
TERMINATIONS OF TENANCY ANYTIME
A TENANCY A TENANT MAKES ANY
SORT OF COMPLAINT REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER IT'S ABOUT.
A POLICY. THAT IS ILLEGAL IN ANY
WAY.
AND OUT FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU. EXODUS.
EXCUSE ME HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THAT COMMITTEE RUN
KINGSTON I REPRESENT FOR
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SOUTHERN CITIES.
EAST BAY ORANGE COUNTY EGGMAN
NORTH VALLEY.
WE TO WAY JOIN THE OPPOSITION IN
THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO PEEL THE
ONION BACK IF YOU WILL TO. LOOK
AT ITS TRUE IMPACT TODAY IN AND
NOTICE A THREE DAY NOTICE TO
PAYER QUIT.
IT'S NOT JUST TO PAY RENT WHICH
YOU ALREADY KNOW.
IT'S ALSO TO STOP.
THE OFFENDING AND OTHER
OFFENDING.
TENANT.
STOP PLAYING THE STEREO AT TWO
THIRTY IN THE MORNING WE DO NOT
BELIEVE IT IS REASONABLE.
TO GIVE THAT OFFENDING TENET
CREATING THAT DISTURBANCE.
ADDITIONAL DAIS.
IT IS A STEP THAT IS A
SUBSTANTIAL ARE ISSUE FOR ALL
THE OTHER TENANTS THAT HAVE TO
ENDURE CONCERNING NON PAYMENT OF
RENT THE THREE DAY NOTICE.
THREE DAY NOTICE IS A REMINDER
NOTICE THAT YOU STILL PAY THAT
NEED TO PAY YOUR RENT WHICH YOU
AGREED TO LET'S SAY IT'S FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
ALMOST EVERY LEAST IN RENTAL
AGREEMENT TODAY HAS A GRACE
PERIOD.
THAT GRACE PERIOD IS USUALLY
FIVE DAYS IF YOUR RENT IS DUE ON
THE FIRST.
THE FIRST TIME THAT YOU CONSERVE
THAT NOTICE IS THE SIXTH DAY OF
THE MONTH.
AND THEN YOUR RENT WOULD BE
OTHERWISE TO ON THE KNIFE.
IN THAT SITUATION THAT SHOULD BE
MORE THAN ENOUGH TIME WHAT.
MISTER CHU IS RECOMMENDING IS A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE TO THAT SO
THE THREE DAY NOTICE TO EXTEND.
IS PROBLEMATIC FOR US
AND IT'S
THAT'S ONE TWO REAL QUICK LIKE.
THE FIVE DAY NOTICE TO ANSWER.
THIS IS A COPY OF THE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER FORM FOR AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER RESPONSE.
TODAY THE TENANT HAS.
S. MISTER CHU AND WITNESSES
INDICATE FIVE DAYS IT WOULD LIKE
THEY ARE REQUESTING A
SUBSTANTIAL.
INCREASE.
HOW DIFFICULT IS
PLEADING WITH THE RESPONSE
CHECK A BOX
ON PAGE ONE?
YOU SIGNED IT.
AND YOU DATA.
THAT SAID THERE IS NO
COMPLICATED THE ISSUE IF YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE.
I GENERAL DESCRIPTION REGARDING
WHY YOUR RESPONSE TO IT
RESPONDING TO IT AND DISPUTE
THIS.
IT YOUR OPTION THAT NO COURT WE.
THAT WE KNOW AND AWARE OF IN
INCLUDING MR STONES ARE ORANGE
COUNTY LOS ANGELES ALAMEDA
SACRAMENTO WE COULDN'T FIND.
ONE WHERE A COURT SAID THIS IS
AN. INADEQUATE RESPONSE.
BY A TENANT THIRD AND FINALLY.
THERE'S A THERE'S A REQUEST FOR
ONCE
THE COURT HAS DETERMINED THAT
THE TENANT IS IN DEFAULT.
TWO WEEK STAND THAT INTEL.
FOR FOURTEEN DAYS UNTIL SUCH
TIME.
THAT.
THEY COULDN'T THAT.
THE LANDLORDS ATTORNEY CAN FILE
A REQUEST FOR DEFAULT JUDGMENT
ENTRY OF JUDGMENT IF YOU WELL.
THIS.
IN GENERAL TERMS IS WELL DOWN
THE PIKE OF A MONTH OR TWO
MONTHS LATER.
ED WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
THERE IS MORE TIME WHAT IS ALL
THIS BOIL DOWN TO.
WE KNOW THAT THAT THE TENANT HAS
AGREED TO PAY RENT.
THE CHAT IS CONTRACTUALLY AGREED
TO IT.
WE DON'T IMMEDIATELY ACT ON THAT
AS THE THAT THAT YOU NEED TO DO
IT. THIS IS THEY WERE GENERALLY
AN AMICABLE RELATIONSHIP.
AND WE ARE LEAD AROUND LIKE TO
KEEP IT THAT WAY.
AND FOR THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR NO
FAULT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION.
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN SAN
DIEGO WE HAVE ONE COURT ONE
JUDGE AT HERE'S THAT YOU DE
CASES IT TAKES BETWEEN THIRTY
AND SIXTY DAYS TO DISPOSE OF
THEM ANY ADDITIONAL TIME. IS
PROBLEMATIC FOR US THEREFORE
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD JUST
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATES AND THEN THAT YOU'RE
OPPOSED PLEASE ANSWER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE FOR.
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ANOTHER
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EMILY I CAN GAP THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSITION.
THE MONTGOMERY A BEHALF FOR THE
CIVIL DISASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
JONATHAN AND ON BEHALF OF THE
APARTMENTS ASSOCIATION OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES IN THE SANTA
BARBARA RENTAL PROPERTY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE AT OPPOSITE.
SAY NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT.
THE QUESTIONS COME.
THIS RACE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
SO THAT WE ARE CLEAR.
GIVING SEVEN DAYS.
TO CURE IF YOU HAVEN'T PAID YOUR
RENT CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT IT'S
GONE FROM THREE DAYS ATTEND SUCH
AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY.
AND IF IT'S IN THE ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY THE INCREASE IS ONLY
TWO DAYS THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THE PROVIDING TWO WEEKS TO
READ TO FILE A RESPONSE.
UNLAWFUL DETAINER TRICON FROM
FIVE DAYS TO FOURTEEN DAYS.
THE QUESTIONS GOVERNMENT'S.
RIGHT SINGER WAS CHIU MIKLOS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEET
FIRST AGAIN THANK THE COMMITTEE
OF FOR YOUR AMENDMENTS AND I
ALSO WANT TO JUST CLARIFY. TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCILS ARE
REQUEST AROUND DELAYED THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO ALLOW
FORMS THAT IS. PERFECTLY FINE
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE SO WHERE
WE'RE WILLING TO DO THAT.
THIS BILL REALLY IS ABOUT
REASONABLE TIME FRAMES AND AND
WE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION THE
SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW.
BY EXTENDING THREE DAYS TO TEN
DAYS FOR ADDING MONTHS TO THE
PROCESS.
BUT WE'RE REALLY ENSURING OUR
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
AVOIDABLE OBJECTIONS WERE
TALKING ABOUT A FEW EXTRA DAYS
THAT WOULD MEAN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN STAINING APARTMENT. AND
BEING KICKED OUT ON THE STREET
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A HOME
AND HOMELESSNESS KIDS BEEN ABLE
STAND SCHOOLS PARENTS BEEN ABLE
TO HANG ON A JOBS.
ASIDE NOT HAVING TO PAY FOR THE
IMPACT
OF ADDICTIONS ON THE SOCIAL
SAFETY NET THE SCHOOL SYSTEM OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM AND.
I KNOW THERE'S A SUGGESTION
THAT WE MODES AND TENANTS ALL
WANT TO MAINTAIN AN AMICABLE
RELATIONSHIP BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SITUATION WHERE. THAT
RELATIONSHIP HAS NOT.
HAS TERMED SOMETHING LESS THAN
AMICABLE LA WHEN SOMEONE'S BEEN
GIVEN A PIECE OF PAPER THAT SAYS
AND SEVENTY TWO HOURS YOUR LIFE
WILL BE COMPLETELY OVERTURNED
AND WHAT WE ARE SUGGESTING IS.
WHICH PROVIDE A FEW ADDITIONAL
DAYS SO THAT THAT HOPEFULLY
DOESN'T HAPPEN ARE I OF COURSE
AM LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN OUR.
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE OPPOSITION
AND TO HOPE THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO GET TO GOOD PLACE BUT.
VERY MUCH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE WORST EVICTION AND TENANT
AND HOUSING CRISIS OUR STATE HAS
EVER EXPERIENCED.
THANK YOU.
SO WE.
I AM ABLE TO TAKE A MOTION THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SO THERE'S A MOTION AS THEIR
SECOND.
AND A SECOND
THANK YOU.
KALRA PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU.
CHIU TYPE CHIU AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO RACE.
REYES I.
THAT HAS FOUR SO WE'LL PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO BONTA.
YOU HAVE TO ITEMS WITH THIS
LET'S TAKE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SIX.
THE FACT IS THAT CLICK OKAY SO.
I.
SOME.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY SIX MOST ABOUT IS BEING
PULLED UNTIL NEXT WEEK CORRECT
OKAY I WILL ALSO ANNOUNCE THAT
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX.
A CHILD'S BILL HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM OUR AGENDA AS WELL AS ITEM
FOURTEEN.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT
BERTUCCI.
SO THOSE THREE BILLS ARE
CURRENTLY OFFER AGENDA SALUTE GO
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN.
THIS WATER THEY MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTEEN. AND FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF HAVE PUT
INTO THIS MEASURE. AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTEEN WOULD ESTABLISH A
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
LANDLORDS AND PROPERTY MANAGERS
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE
CERTIFICATION WILL ENSURE
LANDLORDS AND PROPERTY MANAGERS
HAVE BASIC EDUCATION UNFAIR
PRACTICES
AND TENANT RIGHTS.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS RENT
THE PLACE THEY CALL HOME WITH
INCREASING HOUSING COSTS THE
NUMBER OF RENTERS IN THE STATE
IS ESTIMATED TO CONTINUE.
TWO GROW WHILE CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITS LANDLORDS FROM
ENGAGING IN DISCRIMINATORY
BEHAVIOR THERE IS NO FORMAL
EDUCATION. ON FAIR HOUSING OR
TENANT RIGHTS THAT LANDLORDS AND
PROPERTY MANAGERS ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE IN ORDER TO RENT AND
OPERATE A RESIDENTIAL. UNIT.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN WOULD
CREATE ELABORATE PROPERTY
MANAGER EDUCATION CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM THAT CAN BE COMPLETED IN
PERSON OR ONLINE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IDENTIFYING
APPROVING APPROPRIATE FIGHTERS
OF THE EDUCATIONAL COURSEWORK
CERTIFICATION WOULD BE GRANTED
UPON COMPLETION OF COURSEWORK ON
SUBJECTS SUCH AS ADDICTIONS AND
NOTICES. LIMITATIONS ON
ACQUIRING IN DISCLOSING
IMMIGRATION AND CITIZENSHIP
STATUS AND PROTECTIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AMONG OTHER
THINGS.
WE THINK THIS IS A PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO ENSURING THAT
LANDLORDS AND PROPERTY MANAGERS
ARE AWARE OF THE ONGOING CHANGES
TO TENANTS RIGHTS.
AND M. AND THE LAWS.
I THINK THAT.
.
THERE ARE A GREAT NUMBER OF
LANDLORDS WHO ARE WELL MEANING
BUT NOT MAY NOT BE FULLY
INFORMED OF THE LATEST LAWS AND.
THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT APPLY
TO THEM IN THE RIGHTS THAT THEIR
TENANTS MAY HAVE SO THROUGH
EDUCATION WE THINK WE CAN GET
THOSE OUT WELL MEANING LANDLORDS
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THE
APPROPRIATE LAWS ARE ENFORCED.
AND FOLLOWED.
I THINK THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I VOTE I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
JOIN A STRAUSS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE OAKLAND
WAREHOUSE COALITION THANK YOU
AND THEIR NUMBER OF THE MEMBERS
ARE COUPLE OF SECTIONS OF A
MEMBERS ARE LISTED IN THE BILL.
AND YOUR YES WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING AMENDMENTS AND.
.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT THAT
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER TODAY WERE
TAKING THOSE MOMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLATES.
I THINK IT WAS WRONG TO THINK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND JOHN
STRAUSS OAKLAND WAREHOUSE
COALITION.
ONE OF THE GREATEST DRIVERS OF
DISPLACEMENT IS LACK OF
EDUCATION.
ON BOTH THE TENANT AND THE
LANDLORD SIDE BETTER EDUCATION
AND TENANTS RIGHTS AND LANDLORD
RESPONSIBILITIES CAN HELP
MITIGATE THE HOUSING CRISIS ON A
LARGE SCALE.
IN OAKLAND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
RELATIVELY GOOD TENANTS RIGHTS
BUT MANY LANDLORDS CHOOSE TO
IGNORE THE PROCEDURES LAID OUT
IN A RENTED JUST MEANT PROGRAM.
AND SOME SIMPLY DON'T KNOW THAT
IT EXISTS.
SO CERTAINLY THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THAT ARE OPEN
WAREHOUSE COALITION BRINGS
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS TOGETHER
TO IMPROVE SAFETY IN ON
PERMITTED RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
AS WELL AS PERMITTED SPACES.
SIMPLY TELLING PEOPLE ABOUT
ESTABLISHED AND NEW HOUSING
HABITABILITY LAWS CAN BE ENOUGH
TO COOL DOWN CONTENTIOUS
NEGOTIATIONS US ESPECIALLY.
IN THESE MONTHS SINCE THE
KINGSHIP BUYER THAT WE'VE BEEN
VERY ACTIVE AND.
SO BASIC MANDATORY
CERTIFICATION ALLOWS PROPERTY
OWNERS TO MINIMIZE THEIR
LIABILITY IN THE BAY AREA WE SEE
FRAUDULENT AFFECTIONS POP
FOLLOWED BY UNLAWFUL EVICTION
AFFIRMATIVE SUITS WITH GREAT
FREQUENCY AND WOULD LIKE TO TURN
THAT AROUND WE SUPPORT THE SPELL
THANKS FOR YOUR ATTENTION I'M
HERE FOR ANY QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
ORDERS A CREAM THREE CM BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS A HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTEEN. A WE DID ATTEMPT TO.
REACH A DEAL WITH THE AUTHOR
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE ABLE TO
SEE UNABLE TO SECURE AN
AGREEMENT PRIOR TO COMMITTEE AND
SO WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
BECAUSE THE BILL DOES REQUIRE
ALL REAL ESTATE LICENSEES TO
COMPLETE A MANDATORY PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO PERFORM SERVICES THE
THREE RD LICENSE TO DO UNDER
EXISTING LAW.
ALL REAL ESTATE LICENSEES OR RD
SUBJECT TO.
OVERSIGHT AND A RELOCATION
AUTHORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE.
AND SUBJECT TO THAT.
OVERSIGHT RELOCATION AUTHORITY
FOR MANY THINGS INCLUDING.
FEELING TO IT HERE TO.
STATE FAIR HOUSING LAWS.
AND SO WITH THAT.
WE DO.
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL OF
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS DO NOT SATISFY OUR
CONCERNS AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU KNOW VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS GOOD MORNING
DEBORAH CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
FOR APARTMENT ASSOCIATION A TO
CLARIFY WE'RE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
WE DO ENCOURAGE EDUCATION IN
FACT WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU HAVE INTRODUCED THIS BILL
WERE SIMPLY LOOKING FOR SOME
MORE CLARITY.
AND HOW MANY HOURS A WEEK MUST
BE TAKEN WE'RE LOOKING FOR VERY
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ABOUT WHAT
TYPES OF EDUCATION BECAUSE. IF
ANY OF YOU HAVE OBVIOUSLY
PARTICIPATED IN.
CRAFTING SOME OF THESE LAWS THE
BOOKS ARE. INCHES AND INCHES
THICK SO WE WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR ON WHAT TYPE OF EDUCATION.
AND OF COURSE.
AS STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE AT
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS THERE'S A LOT OF
EDUCATION IT'S ALREADY REQUIRED
BY MANAGEMENT COMPANY PERSONNEL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM
EXEMPTED BECAUSE WE THINK THERE
ARE. POTENTIALLY MILLIONS OF
OWNERS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS COURSE SO WE MAY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT A TIME DELAY
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE GET. THE
THE LANGUAGE CRAFTED CORRECTLY
AND THE EDUCATION COURSES
CREATED IN TIME.
SO WITH THAT.
WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
OF MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT.
EXCUSE A MISTER STONE OF MEMBERS
COMMITTEE RUN KINGSTON
REPRESENTING THE SAME FOUR
APARTMENTS SITUATIONS THAT WE.
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL IS REALLY
REALLY WHY.
AS NOTED BY.
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IT IT.
STATES THAT IT APPLIES TO TEACH
AN OWNER OF TWO WERE MORE UNITS.
AND.
TO COMPLETE THIS COURSE WORK IN
SPECIFIED TIME PERIODS BUT LET'S
LOOK AT THE PRACTICAL
APPLICATION.
THE SCOPE.
THERE ARE NUMBERS OF COMPANIES.
THAT HAVE A LOT OF PERSONNEL
NOT DIRECTLY IF AFFILIATED OR
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SPECIFIC
MANAGEMENT AND DATA DAY
MANAGEMENT. CONTACT BETWEEN
THE TENET.
AND.
THE COMPANY.
THAT.
SHOULD BE EXEMPTED.
BAD VERY SPECIFICALLY CRAFTED
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT. AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE TO.
THERE ARE NUMBERS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHERE ALL THE SUDDEN?
YOU INHERIT PROPERTY THE
FOLLOWING DAY YOU INHERIT A FOUR
PLEX.
THIS HAS NO GRACE PERIOD NOTHING
YOU CAN CAN YOU COLLECT RENT CAN
YOU PERFORM THE SERVICES OF A
TENANT. COMPLAINS ABOUT ABOUT
THIS ALL OF THESE TYPES OF
ISSUES ARE NOT ADDRESSED WE HAVE
MET WITH THE STAFF OF MISTER
BONTA. AND.
OUT SOME OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
MET IN THE DISTRICT ABOUT THIS
THESE ARE IN WHAT WE WANT TO SAY
TO YOU IS.
THIS IS NOT.
KIND OF FULL FULLY COOKED YET
THIS IS A MATTER OF.
THAT WE NEED TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CAREFUL AND CRAFTING I
DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT AN LLC.
A PARTNERSHIP IN A IN A
DISSOLUTION OF MARRIAGE ONE
PERSON HAS A CERTIFICATE THE
OTHER ONE DOESN'T THE
DISSOLUTION HAPPENS. THE NEXT
DAY DO THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
CERTIFICATE.
I DON'T I REALLY DON'T KNOW
THESE ARE HUGE PROBLEMS.
LLC'S LE ALL THAT IN ALL THE
ISSUES THAT WE ARE RAISING WITH
YOU WE WOULD HOPE THAT THIS BILL
REALLY SATISFACTORILY ADDRESSES
SO IF YOU WANT TO TARGET AND
HAVE PEOPLE BE FAMILIAR. THIS
COULD BE GREAT FOR AN APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION A REALTOR
ASSOCIATION DRIVE FOR MEMBERSHIP
TO WRITE. IF YOU REFLECT KIND OF
THINK ABOUT IT. BUT.
OVERALL WE WANT TO TARGET LASER
TARGET HAVE PEOPLE BE FAMILIAR
WITH THE LAW IF YOU HAVE
COMPLETED A COURSE OR YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL. CERTIFICATE BY THE.
ON APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
TRAINING ALL THESE.
LANDLORDS THIS IS NOT JUST TWO
HOURS BUT.
DAYS OF COURSE WORK SHOULDN'T
THAT BE SATISFACTORY IT GOES WAY
BEYOND WHAT MISTER BONTA HAS
ENVISION THAT SHOULD BE EXEMPTED
BECAUSE THAT SHOULD BE
SATISFIED.
SKIN IN OUR JUDGMENT SO THESE
ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS THANK
YOU REALLY NEED TO BE WORKED OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THIS DRESS.
I AM I AM I THERE'S NO QUESTION
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO HAVE
EDUCATION FOR DEALING IN ANY
KIND OF A BUSINESS.
WE DON'T REQUIRE THIS OF OTHER
BUSINESSES
THEY CAN OPEN UP THEIR SHOP AND
THEY HAVE A BUSINESS AND THEY'RE
PROVIDING. EITHER SERVICE OR A.
POOR SELLING GOODS WITHOUT BEING
REQUIRED TO BE CERTIFIED.
TO OWN A BUSINESS
AND.
THAT IS ONE OF MY CONCERNS.
THAT IF YOU JUST OWN TWO UNITS
YOU ALREADY ARE REQUIRED TO DO
THIS.
HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED BUT
ANOTHER ISSUE OF COURSE IS THE
LANGUAGE SO NO THE COURSES WILL
HAVE TO BE OFFERED.
IN MANY DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
THE GENERAL CONCEPT OF EDUCATION
I THINK IS GOOD.
BUT.
THE
ACQUIREMENT OF A CERTIFICATION.
.
IT
FOR SOMEONE WHO OWNS.
SO LITTLE.
IS OF CONCERN AYE AYE I DO HEAR
THAT YOU ARE STE WORKING WITH
THE.
WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW THAT.
.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT I'M SURE
IT WILL BE DEALT WITH.
AS YOU GO FORWARD ON THIS.
BUT THOSE ARE SOME CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SING NONE.
SPONSORED YOU MAY HELLO THANK
YOU AL OUT A LOT OF GOOD POINTS
REYES AND I JUST WANNA THANK THE
OPPOSITION FOR THOSE POINTS I
THINK EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
IS IS IS ONE THAT WE WANT TO
WORK ON AND.
AT THE TRY TO FIND A SOLUTION
FOR TO HELP MAKE THE. THE BUILD
STRONGER I WANT TO START WITH.
THE REALTORS AND I THANK THEM
FOR FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION.%
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PROCESSES THEY WEREN'T GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET FULL APPROVAL OF
A FORMAL POSITION BY TODAY.
BUT.
WE.
ARRIVED AT A PLACE I THINK. CAN
CAN I AM.
THAT I BELIEVE THEY HAVE SAID
THAT THAT I BELIEVE OR IN THEIR.
NEUTRALITY GOING FORWARD WE
JUST WANTED TO FINALIZE THAT
TODAY SO I DID WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT FOR
THE PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION AND.
ALSO FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OF OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
.
THE DETAILS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PROBLEMS SO SHE SHOULD ASK FOR
OUR ARE APPROPRIATE AND AND THEY
SHOULD BE IN THERE AND AND WE
WILL WORK ON THAT LEVEL OF
SPECIFICITY ON THE TOPICS TO BE
TAUGHT THE NUMBER OF HOURS.
THAT WILL BE USED TO.
THAT FOR THE LEARNING WE DON'T
WANT THIS TO BE OVER THE BURDEN
SOMEBODY WANT TO BE SIGNIFICANT
WE DON'T WE DON'T WANT IT TO BE.
SOMETHING THAT.
IT DOESN'T CRITICS UP A
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE IN THE
EDUCATION AND KNOWLEDGE OF OF
THE LANDLORDS AND AND PROPERTY
MANAGERS.
LANGUAGE ACCESS IS CRITICAL.
WE'RE GONNA WORK ON THAT GOING
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THOSE PROPERTY MANAGERS AND
LANDLORDS THAT THAT I'M.
NEED COURSES AND AND LANGUAGES
OTHER THAN ENGLISH HAVE THEM SO
THAT THEY AS A THAT THAT.
EDUCATION IS APPROPRIATE.
IT YOU KNOW I WAS GIVEN SOME
THOUGHT TO ARM THEM ISRAEL'S WAS
SAYING ABOUT.
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T LICENSE
OTHER BUSINESSES WE WOULD LIKE
IT'S A LOT OF THINGS IN IN
ENOUGH IF. FOR.
YOU KNOW THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS WE KNOW WE
LICENSE BARBERS AND AND OTHERS
BUT WE DON'T LICENSE LANDLORDS
AND PROPERTY MANAGERS TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT PEOPLE'S HOMES
ABOUT THE ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD
THE SHELTER THAT THEY HAVE FOR
THEM IN THEIR FAMILY.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD. AND I
I'LL ARGUE THAT THAT OUT WHEN
YOU MAKE THE DECISIONS THAT ARE
OF SUCH FUNDAMENTAL IMPORTANCE
TO A PERSON OR FAMILY AND AND
CALIFORNIAN. THEN YOU SHOULD
HAVE BASIC KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT THE
RULES ARE AND THE LAWS ARE THAT
YOU SHOULD BE ABIDING BY. AND
AND THAT THAT WILL CREATE A
STRONGER RELATIONSHIP AYE WITH
TENANTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO.
I'M.
YOU KNOW THIS THAT IT WAS BETTER
THAN THIS BILL ISN'T FULLY
COOKED IT'S NOT FULLY COOKED.
THE FIRST HOUSE IN THE FIRST
COMMITTEE OF THE INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND UP OPPOSITION
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
CONSULTANTS AND CHAIRS ALWAYS
MAKE IT BETTER. AND TO AS WE
ALWAYS ARE OPEN MINDED.
TO USE THE SUGGESTIONS TO MAKE
A STRONGER BILL GOING FORWARD I
THINK THAT THAT BONES OF IT ARE
GOOD AND STRONG AND EVERYONE
THAT'S SPOKEN OUT HAS SAID THAT
THEY AGREE THAT EDUCATION IS
IMPORTANT.
AND SO.
I AFTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
THE BILL STRONGER AS WE GO
FORWARD TO ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU AND I USED TO LIKE TO
GIVE THE OUT THE LAST WORD BUT I
WANT TO SAY I MEAN YOU'RE MY
MAYBE IT.
YOU HAVE AREAS THAT YOU WANT TO
WORK ON FROM THIS COMMITTEE
STANDPOINT IT SATISFIED.
THE CONCERNS THAT THAT.
I WAS RAISING AND THAT THE THEY
KEEP FROM OUR STANDPOINT.
WE FELT NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED
AND SO FROM THAT STANDPOINT IT'S
IN A FINE STATE I THINK TO MOVE
FORWARD. YOUR WELCOME TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THOSE AREAS
AND AND.
FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DON'T
UNDERMINE YOUR YOUR FINAL
STATEMENT BUT JUST PROCEDURALLY
TO LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT
FROM MY SOMEBODY THAT'S WHAT THE
ANNOUNCER SHOWS THAT. WE FELT
THIS WAS APPROPRIATE TO.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO LOOKING FOR.
MOTION AND THAT MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU CAN
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
VERY FEW MEMBERS BUT CALL THE
ROLL ANYWAY STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHIU.
CHRIS. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO REYES.
I REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS CURRENTLY THREE TO
ONE SO I WILL PUT IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF THANK
YOU.
SECARA.
SO GO TO.
I AM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE
MONNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE WOULD
ESTABLISH AN EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGE PROHIBIT THE
DISCLOSURE OF CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS MAY BETWEEN
EMPLOYEE. AND THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATIVE.
PRIVILEGE IS AN EXCLUSIONARY
RULE OF EVIDENCE THAT PROTECTS
CERTAIN CLASSES OF
COMMUNICATIONS FROM DISCLOSURE
TWO OPPOSING PARTIES AND FROM
ENTRY IT INTO EVIDENCE A LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS.
THE RATIONALE IS THAT ALTHOUGH
CERTAIN INFORMATION MAY BE
RELEVANT IT IS NONETHELESS
EXCLUDED BECAUSE OF OVER
THE CALIFORNIA EVIDENCE CODE
CURRENTLY CONTAINS A NUMBER OF
SPECIFIC PRIVILEGES FOR CERTAIN
COMMUNICATIONS INCLUDING COMMON
PRIVILEGES BETWEEN ATTORNEY AND
CLIENT. OR POSITION AND PATIENT.
LESS COMMONLY CITED PRIVILEGES
EXISTS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELORS AND VICTIMS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE COUNSELORS OF VICTIMS
AND HUMAN TRAPPING CASE WORKERS
AND VICTIMS.
ALTHOUGH IT IS UNFORTUNATE MANY
WORKERS TODAY FACE ISSUES OF
DISCRIMINATION EXPLOITATION
HARASSMENT AND RETALIATION.
OF AN EMPLOYEES DISCUSS ISSUES
AFFECTING THEIR EMPLOYMENT WITH
OFFICIALLY IN REPRESENTATIVE
MOST ALREADY ASSUME THAT SUCH
COMMUNICATIONS ARE CONFIDENTIAL
THAT INFORMATION MAY NOT BE
DISCLOSED THE EMPLOYER OR OTHER
THIRD PARTIES. HOWEVER NO STATE
STATUTE PROVIDES SUCH
COMMUNICATIONS WITH AN
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE NOR HIS
CASE ALL RECOGNIZE.
A PRIVILEGE.
THIS EXTENDS TO INCIDENCES OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT HARASSMENT WHEN A
PLEA PREFERS TO APPROACH HIS ARE
HERE HER. UNION REPRESENTATIVE
RATHER THAN THE HUMAN RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT.
UNION REPRESENTATIVES ARE
IMPORTANT THIRD PARTY WHEN
THERE'S REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
THE EMPLOYER DOES NOT HAVE THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE EMPLOYEE
IN MIND.
AT A TIME WHEN THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT AS EMPOWERED WOMEN AND
OTHERS TO REPORT AND SPEAK OUT.
ABOUT HARASSMENT THE WORKPLACE
ADDITIONAL CONFIDENTIAL AVENUES
TO REPORT THESE INCIDENCES ARE
IN GREATER NEED.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE WOULD
ADD UNION AGENT AND REPRESENT
WORKERS ARE RECOGNIZED PATCHWORK
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE ALONG WITH
ELEVEN EXISTING TYPES OF
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM PRIVILEGE.
BY ALLOWING EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGE BETWEEN WORKERS AND
YOU MET YOU REPRESENTATIVES WE
CAN HELP TO ENSURE THE SAFE
PRIVATE AND FULL DISCLOSURE OF
WORKPLACE CONCERNS AND NEEDS.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT I'M
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE CHAIR AND
THE EXCELLENT RIPPLE OF THE
REPORT.
FROM COMMITTEE STAFF I THAT I
THINK IS AN IS A WONDERFUL JOB.
OF BOTH DESCRIBING OF THE GOALS
OF THIS BILL AS WELL AS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY OPPOSITION.
IN A VERY THOROUGH MANNER.
IN WITH THAT.
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOAT AND WITH THE PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY ARE
MICHAEL'S A SEVILLE EXEC
DIRECTOR VASTLY DISTRICT COUNCIL
FIFTY SEVEN. AND CAITLIN BAKER
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL
SEVILLE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THAT'S ME COUNCIL FIFTY SEVEN I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL IN
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE THAT PLAYS
OUT OUT MORE REGULARLY THAN MOST
MAY THINK ARE IN THE LABOR
RELATIONS AT FIELD AYE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HAVING BOTH BEEN A UNION AGENT.
AS AN ATTORNEY BOTH IN PUBLIC
HAVE BOTH IN HOUSE IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE IN THOSE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT.
THE QUANDARY THAT HIS CREATE
THAT HAS BEEN CREATED THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF LABOR LAW.
PUTS A THAT THE UNION AGENT AND
A REPRESENTED EMPLOYEE IN A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION IN A
SITUATION. WHERE THE UNION
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEE SEEKS THE
ADVICE AND GUIDANCE THAT THE
UNION AGENT IS LEGALLY REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE UNDER THE DUTY OF
FAIR REPRESENTATION?
AND AND THE.
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT THAT.
THAT THAT PROCESS HAS CREATED
AND PUTS BOTH PARTIES IN A
SITUATION IN WHICH.
A BOOK FOR AN ELECTION OF REMEDY
I DECISION MAY BE MADE WHETHER
TO PURSUE A A GRIEVANCE TO THE
CONTRACT OR TO GO THE JUDICIAL
ROUTE.
IT AND SEEK LITIGATION.
THAT THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
INFORMATION EXCHANGE BETWEEN THE
UNION AGENT AND REPRESENT AN
EMPLOYEE CAN BECOME DISCOVERABLE
THROUGH A SUBPOENA BY THE
EMPLOYER AND I HAVE FACED
NUMEROUS. INSTANCES IN WHICH A
SUBPOENA IS ISSUED A AND AND.
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS.
CONFIDENTIAL INTIMATE WRITTEN A
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE UNION
AGE AND THE REPRESENT EMPLOYEES
ARE THEN FORCED TO BE TURNED
OVER TO THE EMPLOYER IN USED. A
AGAINST THAT EMPLOYEE ARE IN
LITIGATION NOTHING IN THIS BILL
CHANGES THE ABILITY FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO THROUGH THIS SKELLY
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS UNDER THE
CONTRACT OR THROUGH DISCOVERY.
DEPOSITIONS AND I THINK AN
EXAMINATION A IN LITIGATION.
PREVENTS THEM FROM DOING
THEIR-JOB IN TERMS OF THE
ABILITY TO
INVESTIGATE HANNAH AND QUESTION
EMPLOYEES OR WITNESSES TO ANY
INCIDENT THAT MAY HAVE OCCURRED
AT THE WORKPLACE BUT THIS
ADDRESSES THE QUANDARY BOTH
LEGAL AND ETHICAL. THAT THE
UNION AGENT AND THE AND THE
EMPLOYEE ARE PUT INTO WHEN THEY
BEGIN TALKING ABOUT AN INSTANCE
THAT MIGHT HAVE OCCURRED AT THE
WORKPLACE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT. PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AGAIN I THINK THE THE COMEDIAN
AND MISTER CHAIR FOR HEARING
THIS TODAY AND WE URGE A. AND I
AM IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS WITH
MR CHEN MEMBERS KITTEN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WHERE CO SPONSORS UP THIS BILL
AND WE WERE SPONSORS OF THE
ORIGINAL MEASURE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
UNION PLAYS A REALLY ESSENTIAL
ROLE IN HELPING TO PROBLEM SOLVE
AT THE WORKPLACE AND THAT CAN
ONLY HAPPEN WHEN WORKERS KNOW
THAT THEY CAN COME AND SPEAK TO
THE UNION WRAP. IT IN A
CONFIDENTIAL WAY THAT ALLOWS YOU
AS THE UNION REP TO EVALUATE THE
SITUATION TO PROVIDE ADVICE TO
SEEK OUT OTHER WORKERS TO FIND
OUT THE EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM.
TO HAVE OFF THE RECORD
CONVERSATIONS WITH MANAGEMENT
ABOUT WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON
HELPS YOU TO SOLVE THOSE
PROBLEMS WITH OUT HAVING TO
BRING IN LAWYERS SO I FIND IT
KIND OF IRONIC THAT. UP
OPPOSITION HAS SUCH A PROBLEM
WITH THIS IDEA THAT WORKERS
WOULD BE ABLE TO TALK
CONFIDENTIALLY WITH THEIR UNION
REP WENT SO OFTEN THAT HELPS YOU
AVOID LITIGATION HELPS YOU AVOID
PROTRACTED.
SPIRITS BECAUSE YOU ARE ABLE TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS MORE INFORMALLY
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT FULL
COMMUNICATION.
I WORKED AS A UNION REP FOR MANY
YEARS BEFORE I CAME HERE TO
SACRAMENTO.
AT THAT TIME IT WOULD NEVER
HAVE OCCURRED TO ME THAT I COULD
BE FORCED TO TESTIFY ABOUT WHAT
MEMBERS TOLD ME CONFIDENTIALLY
THERE IS SUCH A. AN ASSUMPTION
ON THE PART OF THE PARTY IS WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT GRIEVANCES
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE WORKPLACE
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT'S AROUND A
MORE SENSITIVE TOPICS LIKE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION A BUT ALSO WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
RETALIATION FAVORITISM ALL KINDS
OF ISSUES THAT HAPPEN AT A
WORKPLACE THERE IS THAT
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY. AND I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT ALLOWING THE
UNION REP TO DO THAT ESSENTIAL
PROBLEM SOLVING ROLE WITH OUT
HAVING TO ADVISE WORKERS.
IF YOU TELL ME THAT I COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE TO BE A WITNESS
AGAINST YOU THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THAT YOU WOULD
IF YOU WERE IN A FORMAL LEGAL
SETTING WITH THINK THAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF WORKERS. OF THE
UNION AND OF THE EMPLOYER IN
MAINTAINING HARMONIOUS LABOR
RELATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT US WITH
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST OFF WHAT
WILL GO WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WE WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO OUR APPRECIATION
FOR THE THROUGH COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES ON THIS ISSUE.
AND FOR THE REASONS THAT OF OUR
EVEN DISCUSS WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
PLACE INTERNATIONAL UNION ALSO
SUPPORT.
GEN MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH THEIR
AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
MILLION SUPER SUNDAY AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT.
SENATOR BREAUX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SAY NONE OPPOSITION.
IF YOU
CHRIS AND SPACE FOR.
AND THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AND CHAIRMAN STONE A JENNIFER
BROWN BEHALF CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO A A.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE I JUST
WANTED TO REFERENCE A FEW THINGS
DONE IN THE ANALYSIS WITH
REGARDS TO WHO IS THE HOLDER OF
THE PRIVILEGE YOU CAN APPLY THE
PRIVILEGE YOU CAN REFUSE.
FOR ANOTHER THIRD PARTY TO
DISCLOSE THE PRIVILEGE I THINK
THE CONFUSION ON WITH REGARDS TO
OUR INTERPRETATION IS THE
DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY THAT IS
UTILIZED WITHIN THAT EXISTING
PARAGRAPH IT GOES FROM YOU NAY
AGENT. UNION AGENT REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEE FORMER REPRESENTING
EMPLOYEE TO EMPLOYEE AND FORMER
EMPLOYEE THOSE ARE LIKE FIVE
DIFFERENT PARTIES ALL INCLUDED
WITHIN THAT SAME PARAGRAPH AND
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT STATUTORY
INTERPRETATION. THE JNA COURT
WHEN APPLYING THIS WILL LOOK IN
ME.
AND SOON THAT THE. LEGISLATURE
MEANT TO USE DIFFERENT TERMS.
IN THAT SECTION AND WE'RE CREEK
CONFUSION WITH REGARDS TO THE
APPLICABILITY OF THIS
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE WHO IT
PLACE TO WHO CAN REFUSE
DISCLOSURE WHO CAN ASSERT THE
PRIVILEGE THAT WE HAVE. AYE
CONFUSION ON THAT AND RIGHT NOW
IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHAT THEY'RE
NOT ON THE UNION AGING COULD IN
FACT OF. A ISSUE THE PRIVILEGE
AND I PREVENT A THIRD PARTY FROM
ESSENTIALLY DISCLOSING ANY OF
THIS COMMUNICATIONS.
THAT LEADS US EVEN IF IT WAS
JUST ONLY THE REPRESENT OF
EMPLOYEE WHO COULD ASSERT THE
PRIVILEGE WE WOULD STILL HAVE
CONCERNS WE DO BELIEVE. ON THAT
THIS COULD INTERFERE WITH
INVESTIGATIONS WITHIN THE
WORKPLACE AND WITH REGARDS THE
ANALYSIS THAT SAYS THIS IS AN
AVERAGE THREE PRIVILEGE THAT
ONLY COMES UP AN ADJUDICATORY.
ADJUDICATORY UP PROCEEDINGS WE
THINK THE APPLICATION OF A
PRIVILEGE IS MUCH MORE EXPANSIVE
THAN THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE IF AN
EMPLOYER WERE TO GO AND
INVESTIGATE A WORKPLACE ISSUE.
AND.
ASK THE EMPLOYEE WHETHER OR NOT
HE CONSULTED AND TURNING THE
ATTORNEY EMPLOYEE RESPONDED YES
THAT EMPLOYER WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO ASK DURING THAT INTERVIEW
WHAT THE COMMUNICATION WAS
BETWEEN THE ATTORNEY AND THE
CLIENT. BECAUSE AGAIN THEY WOULD
ASSERT THE ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE IF THEY DIDN'T IF THEY
DISCLOSE THAT COMMUNICATION
WOULD NO LONGER BE A PRIVILEGED
COMMUNICATION AND SO I THINK THE
APPLICATION OF THIS PRIVILEGE
GOES FAR BEYOND EDGE AS SIMPLY A
COURT PROCEEDING. OR SIMILAR
TYPE OF PROCEEDING BECAUSE IT'S
UTILIZED ALL THE TIME TO ASSERT.
THE PRIVILEGE WHENEVER A
CONFIDENTIAL OR POTENTIAL
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION IS
REQUESTED TO BE DISCLOSED EVEN
IN AN EMPLOYMENT INVESTIGATION
SO WE HAVE CONCERNS WITHOUT AS
WELL. WILL SERVE OUR CONCERN
THAT THIS.
DEFINITION OF THE CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION GOES FAR BEYOND
JUST ADVICE GIVEN BY UNION AGENT
AND INCLUDES ANY COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE TWO WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S WITH REGARDS TO A VICE BY
THE UNION AGENTS WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH HOW BROAD THAT
TERMINOLOGY IS. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS CREATES A ONE SIDED
SITUATION IN THE EMPLOYMENT.
SITUATION THERE IS NO
MANAGERIAL PRIVILEGE THAT WOULD
BE CORRESPONDING TO THIS WOULD
ONLY BE WITH REGARDS TO UNION
AGENT AN EMPLOYEE AND SO IT
PREVENTS ON FULL DISCLOSURE ON
BOTH SIDES AND CREATES THIS
IMBALANCE IN THE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP WHICH WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS TING
HUTCHINS DELETED CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE WITH THEM COMPANY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO NOTE
THAT.
AT THE GOVERNOR TO FEELS AYE
AYE SHARES THE SAME CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE IN IN VETOING A
SIMILAR MEASURE AND AND EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY NINE.
QUOTE.
IT WITH REGARD TO THAT BELLY
SAYS IS FOR CREATIVE ENTRY
PRIVILEGE I DON'T BELIEVE IT IS
A PERFECT BUT COMMUNICATIONS
WITH THE UNION.
ON EQUAL FOOTING AS A
COMMUNICATIONS ONE SPOUSE
PRESUPPOSITION OUR ATTORNEY.
AND.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO SHARES OUR
CONCERNS THAT THIS COULD
COMPROMISE THE ABILITY OF
EMPLOYERS TO CONDUCT THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION THE WORKPLACE AND
THEN.
THE PROPONENTS BRING UP THE THE
MAJOR MOVEMENT AND AND THOSE AYE
DEBILITY FOR THOSE TO CONDUCT A
INVESTIGATION PROCEED COUNSEL.
WE FEEL THE SAME THING WHICH IS
WHY THE ONE TRY TO CONDUCT A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATIONS AND FOR
THE REASONS THAT MISS PRAYER
STATED I'M WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
WOULDN'T HAVE AT THAT.
WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
BOTH GOOD MORNING DOROTHY
JOHNSON OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALL MY
MY COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THIS MORNING
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. AND.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
FIND THIS ONE HERE.
AND THAT MOTION AND THE SECOND
IS THAT.
IS DO PASS.
SO I THINK THAT THERE THE ISSUE
BROUGHT UP ONE OF THE ISSUES
BROUGHT UP ABOUT THE THE
TERMINOLOGY THAT CAN EASILY BE
ADDRESSED BY JUST ADDING
REPRESENTED BECAUSE IT'S
REPRESENTATIVE OF THOSE FOLKS
AND. I THINK THAT.
A LOT OF SOME OF WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WAS SAYING. THE OLDER
THE PRIVILEGE OBVIOUSLY IS THE
EMPLOYEE IN THIS CASE NOT THE
REPRESENTATIVE AND I DO IN FACT
DISAGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
REASONS FOR VETOING THE BILL
BECAUSE. WE DO HAVE A SITUATION.
WHERE I THINK WE WANT TO CREATE?
AVENUES FOR AT AGGRIEVED
EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
AND TALK TO SOMEBODY ABOUT THAT
OUT HAVING.
THAT WHOLE CONVERSATION OPENED
UP MANAGEMENT CERTAINLY CAN DO
THAT THEY CAN BRING IN ATTORNEYS
THEY THEY HAVE PROCESSES
ULTIMATELY TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH. WITH CONFIDENTIALITY AND
IN TALKING TO SOMEONE IN A WAY
THAT IS NOT ULTIMATELY THAN.
DISCOVERABLE. AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE SO.
I'M VERY COMFORTABLE WITH THIS
BILL MOVING FORWARD I THINK IT'S
IT'S APPROPRIATE THIS PLACE IT
CREATES THE RIGHT KIND OF I
THINK THE RIGHT KIND OF BALANCE
AND GIVES AN EMPLOYEE SOMEPLACE
TO GO. WITH SOME CONFIDENCE AND
I THINK WE SHOULD BE
AFFIRMATIVELY REGARDLESS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MATCHES SETTING
UP A PROCESS WHERE EMPLOYEES IN
ANY ORGANIZATIONS.
HAVE
HAVE A A CONFIDENTIAL A TRUSTED.
INDIVIDUAL WITH WHOM THEY CAN
CAN TALK TO WHO HAS THEIR
INTERESTS IN MIND.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS.
SING NONE MISTER KALRA YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARE.
AND ONCE AGAIN YOUR STAFF ONE
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS IN CLOSING AND
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY BOAT.
THANK YOU.
SO THE MOST IS DO PASS KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RAYOS.
REYES I.
THAT IS FIVE OH AT THIS POINT IT
NEEDS ONE MORE SOME INPUT THAT
BILL ON CALL.
AND THEN OUR LAST BILL IS ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B. THIRTY TO
ELEVEN MISTER KALRA.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
AND IF THE SERGEANTS COULD CALL
MEMBERS SOON AS WE GET DONE WITH
THIS I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
FINISH OF OUR BUSINESS FOR THE
DAY IF WE CAN GET MEMBERS HERE.
AND THIS BILL DOES HAVE SUPPORT
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU ADD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURRS.
AB THIRTY TO ELEVEN REVISED
OPTIONAL ORGAN DONATION SECTION
OF THE STATUTORY ADVANCE HEALTH
CARE DIRECTIVE MODEL FORM TO
MATCH BEST PRACTICES ENHANCE HOW
WE HONOR INDIVIDUALS CHOICE.
REGARDING ORGAN DONATION THE
CURRENT ADVANCE DIRECTIVE ALLOWS
PRINCIPLES TO RESTRICT DONATIONS
THEY SPECIFY DOES NOT REQUIRE A
LIST ORGANS THEY WISH TO DONATE
THE IMPROVEMENT IN AB THREE TO
ALL OF ELEVEN VERY ATTEMPTING TO
ACHIEVE. WHAT INCLUDE OF NUMBER
ONE A CHOICE FOR A VERY BROAD
AFFIRMATION OF ORGAN DONATION
AND ALSO SPACE TO WRITE DOWN ANY
RESTRICTION OR LIMITATION IS THE
PRINCIPAL? WANTS TO IMPOSE NOT
JUST RESTRICTION ON THE TYPES OF
ORGANS OR TISSUES.
THE BILL ALSO HARMONIZES A
DONOR'S CHOICE BY DISCLOSING THE
POTENTIAL USE OF TEMPORARY
MEDICAL PROCEDURES UPON DEATH
WHICH MAY CONFLICT WITH OTHER
END OF LIFE CHOICES AND THE
DIRECTIVE.
LASTLY THE BILL MORE CLEARLY
EXPLAINS THE DONOR WHAT THEIR
CHOICE MEANS.
I DENOUNCES POINTS OUT THE BILL
PROVIDES GREATER INFORMATION TO
POTENTIAL DONORS IT SHOULD.
SHOULD ANY A DONOR DISAGREE.
DEPENDS DONORS AND SHOULD I
DON'T DISAGREE THAT DON'T I
COULD ALWAYS REVISED A POINT TO
MAKE IT WHICH IS CLEAR OR ELECT
TO NOT BE A DONOR.
ADDITIONALLY THE DONOR CAN
ALWAYS CHOOSE NOT TO AGREE TO
ANY TEMPORARY MEDICAL PROCEDURES
UPON DEATH BY DELETING THAT
SENTENCE IN THE DIRECTIVE ARE
MAKING CLEAR AND OTHER SECTIONS.
THESE CHANGES AND AB THREE TO
ELEVEN TAKE A MODEST STEP ADDING
CLARITY TO DONORS CHOICE AND
MAKE THE USE OF ADVANCED
HEALTHCARE DIRECTIVE MORE
EFFECTIVE POOR OLD OR OTHER
ORGAN DONATIONS.
BY DOING SO THE BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE THE USE
THESE DIRECTORS ARE PURPOSES
ORGAN DONATIONS.
PUBLIX THOUSANDS REMAIN ON A
WAITING LIST FOR A LIFESAVING
TRANSPLANT.
THE ADVANCE HEALTH CARE
DIRECTIVE MODEL FORM HAS NOT
BEEN CHANGED SINCE ITS CREATION
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE. THAT
NATIONAL BEST PRACTICES AND
EXPERIENCES FROM OTHER STATES
REGARDING OPTIONAL ORGAN
DONATION HAVE.
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE.
AB THIRTY TO ELEVEN REFLECTS
THESE BEST PRACTICES BY GETTING
POTENTIAL DONORS. MORE CHOICE
AND INFORMATION AT THE SAME
TIME.
I WOULD MEAN TO PROVIDE.
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE
THOSE SPONSORS JIM MARTIN CEO OF
DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA. AND TONI
CHICKA TELL ETERNIA CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM.
THANK YOU FIRST WHAT SPLITS GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS JIM
MARTIN CEO OF DAILY LIFE
CALIFORNIA THE CO SPONSOR OF AB
THIRTY TO ELEVEN.
FROM A LIFE CALIFORNIANS THE
STATE AUTHORIZED NONPROFIT AYE
TISSUE ORGAN.
HER HIM HIDING TISSUE DONATION
REGISTRY. OVER FOURTEEN AND A
HALF MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
CURRENTLY REGISTERED HIS DONORS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
CALIFORNIANS HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIGN UP FOR THE
ORGANIZED TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY
ON THE DMV'S DRIVERS LICENSE AND
ID APPLICATION OR RENEWAL FORM.
NINE POINT NINETY FIVE PERCENT
OF DONORS COME THROUGH THE DMV
LICENSE RENEWAL PROCESS.
AND DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTANTLY LOOKING TO IMPROVE
DONOR REGISTRATION RATES ACROSS
THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA
REGISTRATION RATE OF FORTY SIX
AND A HALF PERCENT TRAILS THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF FIFTY FOUR
PERCENT.
AB THIRTY TO ELEVEN WILL
CONTINUE OUR ACCESS TO THOSE
USING THE STATE ADVANCED
HEALTHCARE DIRECTIVE.
TEMPLATE TO DESCRIBE THEIR
HEALTHCARE WISHES WELL FURTHER
CLARIFYING THE MEANING OF EACH
CHOICE ON THE FORM THINK.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT PLEASE
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MEANINGS
TONY CHICKEN TELMA STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM WORK CO SPONSORED THE
BILL.
SO CALIFORNIA HAS A ADVANCE
DIRECTIVE IN THE PROBATE CODE
SECTION THREE OF THE OF THE
FORM.
OFFERS THE PRINCIPLE THE ABILITY
MAKE ANATOMICAL GIFTS.
AND AS A LEGAL AID ATTORNEY FOR
SEVERAL YEARS I DID.
THEIR FORM WITH HUNDREDS OF
CLIENTS
AND A LOT OF THEM FOUND SECTION
THREE CONFUSING.
AND THE CONFUSION LED TO THEM
OFTENTIMES MAKING MISTAKES AND
OF EVEN MORE OFTEN.
SKIP IN THAT SECTION ALL
TOGETHER. MAYBE THIRTY TO ELEVEN
SIMPLIFIES THE CHOICES AND
HOPEFULLY WILL PRODUCE SOME OF
THAT CONFUSION. IT OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR BROADER
EXPRESSION OF PREFERENCES V.
THERE FOR OR AGAINST ORGAN
DONATION. AND ALSO HOPEFULLY
WILL GIVE A LITTLE BETTER
GUIDANCE TO.
THE SURROGATE HEALTHCARE
DECISION MAKER.
RELATED TO ANATOMICAL GIFTS AND
I'D LIKE TO DO FOR THE REST OF
MY TIME TO THE WIDOW OF A FORMER
BOARD MEMBER OF OURS LINDA
MILLER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M LINDA MILLAR.
I'M FROM FREMONT.
AND ARM LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY THIS MORNING.
BECAUSE SOME AS TONY JUST
ANIMATED.
.
ORGAN DONATION IS VERY CLOSE TO
MY HEART YOUR PERSONAL
STANDPOINT.
IN OCTOBER I TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN MY HUSBAND TIMOTHY
MILLAR.
I COME TO ADVANCED LIVER
FAILURE.
A AFTER TWO YEARS OF TRYING
PAINSTAKINGLY TO GO OUT ON A
TRANSPLANT LIST.
IT WASN'T TILL HE WAS THAT IS
VERY SICKEST.
BUT HE RANKS HIGH ENOUGH TO BE
MATCHED WITH A DONOR.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY BY THEN THE
WAITED BEEN TOO LONG.
ON THE DAY A LIVER WAS FINALLY
MADE AVAILABLE FOR HIM TIM DIED
ON THE OPERATING TABLE.
AS PAINFUL AS IT WAS FOR MY
FAMILY DURING TIM'S ILLNESS AND
IN THE EIGHTEEN MONTHS SINCE HIS
DEATH.
WE'RE JUST MONEY ONE OF MANY
CALIFORNIAN FAMILIES WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN THIS EXACT SAME
PREDICAMENT.
THE NEED OF COURSE.
FOR DONORS OUT PACES THE SUPPLY
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY TO THIRTY
TO ELEVEN WILL HELP NARROW THAT
GAP BY PROVIDING.
ADVANCE DIRECTIVE LANGUAGE TO
BETTER FOR FILL THE WISHES OF
DONORS.
WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
LISTENING.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
WAS RIGHT.
I JUST.
WANT TO THANK.
THANK YOU.
I THINK TESTIMONY FROM SOMEONE
WHO LIVES IT AND WHO REALIZES.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE THIS COULD
MAKE?
YOUR TESTIMONY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ON CREDIT. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
L. AND A SECOND ALREADY ON THIS
BILL.
BUT THIS WAS KALRA YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK MISTER ELSE ONE OF THE I
THINK I WITNESSES FOR
TESTIFYING.
DE IT'S ALWAYS DIFFICULT TO
REPEAL VERY PERSONAL THINGS AND
FOR YOU TO DO THAT IN THIS
PUBLIC FORUM IS VERY MEANINGFUL
AND SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND.
YOUR COMMITTEE STOP FOR THE AYE
RECOMMENDATION WAS LIKE AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU. CHIU GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
HOLDEN KALRA AYE AYE KALRA AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN. MANGE AND
I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT IS FIVE OH. THEN PUT OUR
CALL.
IT'S STILL NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE.
HE HAS TWENTY TWO BILLS NOTHING
IS ACTUALLY DISPOSED OF GET
TODAY ONE WAY OR THE OTHER. WE
COULD PLEASE GET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BACK THEN WE COULD GO
THROUGH I THINK EVERYTHING
FAIRLY QUICKLY I WOULD HOPE.
.
YEAH LET'S START WITH.
INSIDE THE GENDER ALTHOUGH
EVERYTHING'S GOING TO GO ON CALL
SO.
OKAY SO THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON CONSENT.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
DOWN I STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU.
CHIU GONZALEZ FLETCHER FOR
CONSENT. AND THOSE FLETCHER AYE
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES. REYES AYE.
BUT WHAT DOES OUR HOUSE OMEGA IS
OKAY SO THAT'S FOR ITEMS AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FRIEDMAN AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX OBERNOLTE.
A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY TWO GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND A. B. THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX WALDRON.
SO LET'S START FROM THE TOP SEE
IF WE CAN GET SOME.
MOTIONS ITEM NUMBER ONE IS A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE SANTIAGO IS
THERE A MOTION.
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU. CHIU GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS A BE NINETEEN EIGHTY
QUIRK.
I NEED A MOTION THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS DO
PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN. MENTION I
REYES.
REYES I.
THE BILLIS OUTS ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE CHIU.
MOTION IS TO PASS NEED A MOTION.
MOTION AND A SECOND TO PASS
KALRA PLEASE.
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS ON CALL.
AND NUMBER FIVE WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA I NEED A MOTION ON
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY SIX GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THERE'S A MOTION.
IS THERE SECONDS.
AND A SECOND THAT IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT MEANS ONE MORE SO THAT IS
ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS ON CALL
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY SIX GARCIA.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU CHIU
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RAYOS RATES ARE.
AND IS ONE MORE SO WE WILL PUT
IT ON CALL. ITEM NUMBER NINE IS
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND NEED A
MOTION.
AS A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE REYES.
REYES I.
THAT PHYLLIS. OUTFITS
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX CHAU HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA ITEM ELEVEN. IS
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH TO FRIEDMAN
MADE A MOTION.
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE I CUNNINGHAM CHAU
CHIU GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE IS AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SANTIAGO NEED A
MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU CHIU. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES.
REYES I.
THE BILL IS OUT.
I REMEMBER THIRTEEN IS A B..
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE IS ON CALL
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY EIGHT MINUTES WHICH
IS WHAT PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN. A. B.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY NINE COOPER
NEED A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU THAT IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHEN CHAO CHIU. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES.
REYES I.
I NEED ONE MORE SET UP BILL IS
ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB THIRTY TO
ELEVEN IS ON CALL AND NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB THIRTY TO TWELVE
IRWIN AND EMOTION.
AND HERE'S THE MOST IN A SECOND
THAT IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU CHIU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I'VE REYES.
REYES I.
A GAS MISTER CHIU SO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB THIRTY TO ELEVEN.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN IS SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
SENATOR WIENER.
LOOKING FOR A MOTION.
A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED. CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU CHIU. CHU AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES I.
OKAY DOT THAT BILL IS OUT.
SO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS ON
CALL.
ALRIGHT LET'S.
.
I DON'T.
I DO NOT LET'S GO THROUGH THE
LIST ONE MORE TIME.
INCLUDING LIFTING THE CALLS AND
REPLACING BECAUSE IF NECESSARY
SO THAT EVERYBODY WHO'S HERE CAN
AT LEAST GET VOTED AND IF WE CAN
GET. EVERYBODY ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE HERE WEEK THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED.
OKAY CONSENTS.
THOSE THAT.
THOSE ARE ALREADY OUT BUT WE'RE
GOING TO ADD ABSENT MEMBERS.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM OUT I
CHAO.
CHIU CHU AYE HOLDEN.
OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER ONE I'M GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL THAT IS A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE SANTIAGO.
CALLED.
MUCH WITH THE VOTE WAS CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CHAO.
CHU CHU AYE.
HOLDEN.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO IS OUT THAT WILL
ADD ABSENT MEMBERS THAT IS AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY QUIRK.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS ON CALL I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL THAT IS
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
BECAUSE IT'S A MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS ALSO ON
CALLING GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE
CHIU.
CALLING UP THE NUMBERS CHAU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
THAT IS ONE MORE I'M GOING TO
REPLACE THE CALL.
I REMEMBER FIVE WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX IS ON
CALL GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
CALYPSO MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE AYE CHAU CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS ON CALL
TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN BONTA I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU.
CHIU. CHU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
REYES.
KILEY NO REYES.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE SONG GOING
TO REPLACE THE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS ON CALL
THAT IS AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU.
CHIU.
TRUE I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
FABULOUS ADDS
ITEM NUMBER NINE.
IS OUT BUT WE CAN CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO WHO WANT TO
ADD ON KENNY AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
ITEM NUMBER TEN WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN IS
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH TO IT IS OUT
BUT CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WHO WHICH OUT ON. CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SANTIAGO IS OUT BUT
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS WHO WISH
TO ADD ON. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE CHAU CHIU. CHU AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE. ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
A. B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
KALRA IS ON KONG WAY TO LIFT THE
CALL CALYPSO MEMBERS. CUNNINGHAM
NO CUNNINGHAM NO CHAO CHU CHU
AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN WAS PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE COOPER. IS ON CALL THE LIST
THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM IS NO CHAU.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB THIRTY TO
ELEVEN KALRA IS ON CALL ON THE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
THAT BILL WAS OUT ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN IS OUT BUT IT WILL ADD
ON ABSENT MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
THAT'S A. B. THIRTY TO. TWELVE
IRWIN.
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN IS S. B.
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE WIENER THE
BILL IS OUT BUT WE CAN.
NEVER SWITCHED AT ON.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CHAU.
I NUMBER EIGHTEEN.
CHAU AYE. HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
OKAY.
SO I DON'T EVER FIFTEEN EIGHTY
A. B. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY NINE.
CUNNINGHAM CHANGING ROME NO
TONIGHT OR NOT.
ALRIGHT LET'S ROLL THROUGH THIS
AGAIN STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHOW. CHOW I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
THAT IS COMPLETE ITEM NUMBER ONE
IS AB NINETEEN FORTY NINE
SANTIAGO CALL THE US MEMBERS
CHAU. CHOW AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
HEY.
ITEM NUMBER TWO IS A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY QUIRK CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHOW. CHOW AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY FIVE CHU COOLEY
ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHAU.
CHAU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY THREE CHIU IT IS ON
CALL AND WIN A LIST TO CALL.
CHAU.
CHAO I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
CHAU
SHALL I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN BONTA WHEN
IT'S ON CALL AND WIN A LIST THE
CALL COOLEY UP TO MEMBERS. CHAU
CHOW I.
REYES
.
OKAY WELL WE'LL FIGURE THAT ONE
OUT THOSE ITEMS ARE THAT WAS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
OKAY ITEM.
NUMBER EIGHT A. B. TWENTY SIX.
THIRTY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA.
COLUMNS OF NUMBERS CHAU CHOW I.
AND ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TWO GONZALEZ
FLETCHER CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHOW. CHOW I.
I REMEMBER TEN WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA ITEM.
NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT.
TO FRIEDMAN COLLAPSE. CHOW CHOW.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SANTIAGO CALL IF THE
NUMBERS CHOW CHOW I.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B..
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE KALRA
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS CHAU CHAU
AYE.
ITEM FOURTEEN WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA ITEM FIFTEEN AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY NINE COOPER.
CHAU CHOW I.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN THIRTY TO
ELEVEN KALRA.
CHAU CHOW I.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN.
AB THIRTY TO TWELVE IRWIN CHOW
CHOW I.
AND WE HAVE A LOT.
OKAY
LET OF EFFORTS GO
OKAY SO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN WE'RE
RECORDING THIS RACE AS.
AND I VOTE THAT WE JUST
CORRECTING THE RECORD THERE THAT
BILL IS OUT.
SO ALL OF OUR BUSINESS.
DOUBLE CHECKING.
ALL OVER BUSINESS IS DONE
EVERYBODY HAS VOTED WITH THAT WE
ARE ADJOURNED